ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ
ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव लेट मी चेक वंस
गाइस गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी नमस्ते सबको
एंड प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड
विजिबल क्लियरली मुझे एक बार जल्दी से बता
दीजिए कि मेरी ऑडियो वीडियो बिल्कुल
परफेक्टली आ रही है आप सभी को सभी लोग
अच्छे से सुन पा रहे हैं देख पा रहे हैं
सो प्लीज कंफर्म इट एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग
टू ऑल ऑफ यू नमस्ते टू एवरीबडी
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
गुलगुल इवनिंग
ओके चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात है
हां जी गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड
इवनिंग सबको नमस्ते नमस्ते ओके एवरीथिंग
इज़ क्लियर एकदम फाइन परफेक्टली फाइन
ओके गुड मॉर्निंग गुड मॉर्निंग गुड गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
बॉस गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग भाई गुड इवनिंग
बहुत-बहुत गुड इवनिंग। वेरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वेरी गुड
इवनिंग। बहुत-बहुत गुड इवनिंग। चलिए।
सो सबसे पहले तो मैं आपसे कुछ चीजें
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] बोल देता हूं
पहले। देन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वी विल स्टार्ट टू मैं यहां पे फोन ले
लेता हूं।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
हम
बिफोर वी स्टार्ट फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल आई वुड
लाइक टू टेल एवरीबडी हियर प्रेजेंट हियर
कि आप लोग एक काम जो है वो जरूर से जरूर
कीजिए क्योंकि उसके कारण क्लासेस डिले
होती हैं। एंड उसमें आपको जेन्युइन रहना
है। उसमें आपको अ
फेक चीजें नहीं करनी है। फेक का मतलब है
कि जेन्युइन मैं क्यों बोल रहा हूं ऐसा
मैं आपको अभी बताता हूं। आपको सबसे पहले
तो हर क्लास की जब भी क्लास खत्म हो जाती
है तो आपको यहां पर
हर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सेशन पे कम
से कम 200 प्लस कमेंट्स आपको करने हैं। वो
भी जेन्युइन एंड यूनिक कमेंट्स। यानी एक
बंदा सिर्फ एक ही आईडी से कमेंट करना है
आपको। यू डोंट हैव टू डू मल्टीपल कमेंट्स
फ्रॉम सिंगल आईडी। क्योंकि हम उसको सिंगल
कमेंट ही काउंट करते हैं। पिछली बार जब एक
बार काफी सारे कमेंट्स आ गए थे बहुत जल्दी
विद इन 24 आवर्स। तो मुझे डाउट हुआ था। तो
मैंने जब पता करवाया तो मैंने देखा कि एक
बंदा जो है वो उसने पता नहीं कितने
कमेंट्स करे थे। उसको मैंने हाइड कर दिया
चैनल से। एंड द कमेंट गॉट इवन लेस देन
200। तो सोचो 300 प्लस कमेंट हो गए थे। तो
ऐसा नहीं करना। जेन्युइन रहना है आपको। जब
मैं आपके साथ जेन्युइन हूं तो आपको भी
मेरे साथ जेन्युइन रहना है इस चीज के लिए।
राइट? एंड आपको 200 प्लस कमेंट्स करने हैं
हर वीडियोस पे। ठीक है? एंड देन जो है
आपकी क्लासेस बिल्कुल आती रहेंगी। बस मेरा
एक यही कंडीशन है और कोई कंडीशन है नहीं।
वीडियोस को तो आप शेयर करते ही हैं जिनके
साथ शेयर करना है अपने जो भी लाइकेबल इसके
ऑडियंसेस हैं या जो भी एंथूजियास्ट हैं
एसओसी से एसओसी सीखना चाहते हैं एसओसी
एंथोजियास्ट हैं उनके साथ आप शेयर करते
हैं आई नो एंड अब गिव अवे की अनाउंसमेंट
होगी एक-द दिनों में तो ग्रुप में जरूर
एक्टिव रहिएगा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
ये काम आपको कर देना है सबसे सबसे पहला
काम दूसरा वीडियो के जब आप वीडियो देखने
जाते हैं वो रिकॉर्डिंग तो वहां पे एक
हाइप का बटन होता है एक हाइप करने का
ऑप्शन मिलता है हाइप कर दीजिएगा जितना आप
हाइप करेंगे वीडियो उतने रिकमेंड करता है
YouTube वीडियोस को दूसरे व्यूअर्स को
पोटेंशियल व्यूअर्स को तो उससे जो है
वीडियोस जो है हर जगह पहुंच पाती है।
नेक्स्ट इज़ कि यह मेरा Lindin प्रोफाइल
है। आप इस पे आके मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। 12,000 लोग भी
मुझसे कनेक्ट अभी तक हो चुके हैं एंड फॉलो
कर चुके हैं। एंड काफी लोग जो हैं वो
इंटरेक्ट करते हैं। तो आप इसके थ्रू मुझसे
इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं। फर्दर Lindin पे
जाके डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च कीजिएगा। तो
डिफ़ॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी हमारा जो हमारी
कंपनी का Lindin पेज है उसको जरूर फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। तो हमारी कंपनी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का Lindin पेज
आपको मिल जाएगा। एंड देन यू विल गेट
अपडेट्स ऑफ आवर कंपनी हियर। जैसे एक
स्टार्टअप किस तरीके से स्केल हो रहा है,
कैसे हम क्या-क्या चीजें करने जा रहे हैं,
वो सब कुछ आपको इस पेज पे जो है वो मिल
जाएगी। एंड इस पे आपको डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ
पोस्ट्स जो है वो भी मिलते हैं। जो हम
दूसरे लर्नर्स हैं जब उनको कोई किसी चीज
को लेके प्रेज़ करते हैं, कोट करते हैं या
कुछ भी तो आपको यहां पे यह मिल जाएगा।
जैसे अभी इन्होंने यहां पे एक हॉल ऑफ फेम
मिला था इनको तो इनको हमने टैग भी किया
था। कोट भी करा था। तो ये आप फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा इस पेज को। यहां पे 21,000 लोग
हमसे जुड़े हैं। यह तो YouTube चैनल है।
तो इसमें सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है कि अगर
आप सब्सक्राइब नहीं है तो सब्सक्राइब तो
कर लेना। बाकी अगर सब्सक्राइब हो भी तो यह
बेल ऑल वाला ऑप्शन ज़रूर देख लेना, चेक कर
लेना। अगर ना हो तो इसको सेलेक्ट कर लेना,
ऑन कर लेना। इससे नोटिफिकेशन आपको मिल
जाएगी। अगर इसको ऑन नहीं करते हो तो कई
बार कई नोटिफिकेशंस आपको नहीं मिलती है।
एंड उस केस में क्या होता है कि आपको
वीडियोस का पता नहीं चल पाता। कई बार मेरे
पास आते हैं मैसेज कि सर आपने लाइव कराया
था। मुझे तो बहुत लेट नोटिफाई हुआ। मुझे
नोटिफाई ही नहीं हुआ। मैंने जब ओपन करके
चैनल देखा तब वो वीडियो आई थी
वगैरह-वगैरह। तो इसका प्रॉब्लम इस
प्रॉब्लम का सॉलशन है ये। यह आप कर
लीजिएगा। दूसरी हर एसओसी के वीडियोस के
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट यह स्टेप है। हर एसओसी के
वीडियो किसी भी एसओसी के वीडियो को जब आप
ओपन करेंगे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एंड यहां पे आप इसको
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक्सपेंड करेंगे
डिस्क्रिप्शन को तो यहां दो लिंक मिलते
हैं आपको। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का लिंक
मिलता है आपको। दूसरा WhatsApp चैनल का
लिंक मिलता है। इस दोनों को ओपन कर लेना
है। WhatsApp ग्रुप जो है ये एसओसी का
स्पेशल स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है। जहां आपको
एसओसी से रिलेटेड जितने रिसोर्सेज मैं
आपको यहां पे दिखाता हूं। मैं आपको वहां
पे बताता हूं। वो सब रिसोर्सेज एंड नोट्स
एंड पीडीएफ, पीपीटीस जो भी है ना वो सब
आपको इसी ग्रुप में मिलेंगी। तो इसमें
जरूर जॉइ करना है आपको। जितने भी आने वाले
अपकमिंग अपडेट्स हैं एसओसी के क्लासेस के
रिगार्डिंग, अपकमिंग सर्टिफिकेशन के
रिगार्डिंग, अपकमिंग टेस्ट्स के
रिगार्डिंग, इंटरव्यूज के रिगार्डिंग वो
सब इसी ग्रुप में मिलने वाला है। तो इसको
जरूर जॉइ करना है आपको। ठीक है? अगर आप
इसको ज्वाइन नहीं करते हैं तो आपको किसी
तरह की कोई अपडेट नहीं मिल पाएगी। एंड फिर
आप मुझसे कनेक्ट नहीं कर पाएंगे। उसके बाद
है ये हमारा WhatsApp चैनल डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी ये आप चैनल सेक्शन में WhatsApp पे
जाके एक्सप्लोर पे जाके आप सर्च भी करेंगे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स तो वो भी आ जाएगा अदरवाइज आप
लिंक पे जाके इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
क्योंकि जितने भी अपडेट्स हैं ओवरऑल
अपडेट्स टोटल इन टोटल अपडेट्स वो इसी चैनल
पे आपको मिलती है सबसे पहले बस यह हमारा
डेफ्रोनिक्स का Lindin Twitter या एक्स
पेज है। इस पे आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। ये
हमारा Instagram हैंडल है जहां पे 500 के
लगभग लोग हमसे जुड़े हैं। जहां पे इनफेटिव
इनेशन से भरी आपको रील्स कंटेंट्स मिल
जाएंगे। ये हमारी वेबसाइट है। इस पे आके
आप वेबसाइट को एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिए। एकडमी
पे जाके हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को आप एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं। एंड यहां पे हमारा नंबर है
जिस पे आप हमारी कोई किसी भी तरह की
क्वेरी जो है कर सकते हैं। ये सारी चीजें
हो गई। आज का जो टॉपिक है, आज का जो
सेक्शन जो हम स्टार्ट करने जा रहे हैं
एसओसी के लिए वो है हमारा नेटवर्किंग
सेक्शन। ठीक है? नेटवर्किंग सेक्शन जो है
आपके लिए उतना ही इंपॉर्टेंट है एसओसी में
जितनी बाकी सेक्शंस हमने अभी तक डील करी
है। हमने जो भी चीजें सीखी आपने देखा होगा
स्टार्टिंग मैंने एसओसी के फंडामेंटल से
करा था। एंड धीरे-धीरे मैंने साइबर
सिक्योरिटी वाला मॉड्यूल खत्म किया। देन
अब नेटवर्किंग के मॉड्यूल पे मैं आया हूं।
नेटवर्किंग का मॉड्यूल जब खत्म हो जाएगा
उसके बाद हम लॉग्स एंड ओएस से रिलेटेड कुछ
मॉड्यूल्स हैं। वो पढ़ेंगे वो जानेंगे।
एंड देन जो है हम डीप ड्राइव करेंगे
एसआईएम या जो एसओसी से रिलेटेड जितने भी
इंपॉर्टेंट टूल्स एंड टेक्नोलॉजीस जिस पे
एक्चुअली एसओसी एल1 ऑपरेट करते हैं काम
करते हैं हम उनको डील करेंगे तब हमारा
प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट थोड़ा ज्यादा होगा थोड़ी
एनालिटिकल पार्ट जो है वो थोड़े ज्यादा
एनालि एनालाइज करने का आपको तरीका पता
चलेगा एंड तभी आप समझ पाएंगे उस टाइम पे
कि क्यों हमने ये बेसिक्स क्लासेस करी
हैं। क्यों हमने ये बेसिक्स टॉपिक्स पढ़े
हैं? कितना इंपॉर्टेंट हमारे लिए ये
टॉपिक्स जो ये हमारे टॉपिक्स थे वो थे एंड
क्यों इसके बिना आगे के क्लासेस अधूरे
हैं। तो मैं जितने भी व्यूअर्स हैं, जितने
भी लर्नर्स हैं उन सब से एक रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि अगर आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हैं या
बाद में इन क्लासेस को देख रहे हैं कभी भी
इन फ्यूचर तो एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि प्लीज
क्लासेस को आप लाइन बाय लाइन जैसे मैंने
कराया है क्लास वन टू थ्री फोर वैसे ही
देखें। ऐसा नहीं कि बीच से कोई भी क्लास
उठा लिया उसको देख लिया क्योंकि मैं एक
हायरार्की में आपको पढ़ा रहा हूं सिखा रहा
हूं क्योंकि मैंने आपसे बोला है कि ये एक
जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग है। राइट? मैंने आपको
बोला है जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग। अब जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग ऐसे ही नहीं हो जाती कि कुछ भी
लाके, कहीं से भी ला के किसी भी तरीके से
आपके सामने परोस दिया और आपने उसको खा
लिया। राइट? अब देखो खाना खाने के भी
मल्टीपल तरीके हो सकते हैं। एक आपने क्या
किया? आपने एक राइस उठाई। ठीक है? एक बाउल
लिया उसमें राइस उठाई। उसमें आपने
वेजिटेबल मिलाया। उसमें आपने दाल वगैरह
मिक्स किया। उसमें आपने और भी दो दो तीन
चीज़ें जो खाने की चीज़ें हैं। चटनी वगैरह
हो गई या सैलेड वगैरह हो गया। सब मिक्स
किया और सबको खा लिया। ये एक तरीका होता
है। एक तरीका होता है राइस एक अलग बाउल
में दाल एक अलग बाउल में आपकी सब्जियां
अलग रखी हुई है। सैलेड अलग रखा हुआ है।
ऐसे करके आप इंसानों की तरह प्यार से खा
रहे हैं। तो दोनों में आप खा तो रहे हैं
खाना। बट एक जो है वो आपकी क्या दिखाता है
आपको? आपका आपको एक अलग तरीके से शोकेस
करता है। दूसरा जो तरीका है वह आपको एक
अलग तरीके से शोकेस करता है। पहले तरीके
में जब सब मिक्स करके खा रहे हैं तो आपको
कोई भी देखेगा तो कहेगा अरे यार कैसे खा
रहा है ये। राइट? हालांकि हम खा रहे हैं।
राइट? बट वी आर ह्यूमंस राइट? तो हम थोड़ा
एक तरीके से चीजों को करते हैं। बट दूसरे
तरीके में आप तरीके से कर रहे हैं। तो वो
एक अलग इंप्रेशन देता है। राइट? तो उसी
तरीके से जब आप इंटरव्यूअर के पास जाते
हैं तो आप अगर सब कुछ मिला के कचरा परोसते
हैं सामने तो इंटरव्यूअर आपसे ऑब्वियसली
बात है कभी भी किसी भी तरीके से इंप्रेस
नहीं होने वाला है। एंड उसको कोई फर्क
नहीं पड़ेगा। आपको सीधा ना बोल देगा। उसके
पास और बहुत सारे कैंडिडेट्स लाइन में लगे
हुए हैं। तो अगर आप सेकंड तरीके से बहुत
प्यार से स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में उसको सब चीज
बताते हो। एक-एक करके डील करते हो। एक-एक
पॉइंट को समझ समझ समझ समझाते हो उसको एंड
एक-एक चीजों को नॉलेज में रख के उसको
बताते हो बातें करते हो तो वह इंप्रेस
होगा और आपको फिर ऑब्वियसली बात है आपके
चांसेस हायर होने के या सिलेक्ट होने के
बढ़ जाते हैं। ये मैटर आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा। ये डिफरेंसेस समझ में आया होंगे।
दैट्स व्हाई आई एम गोइंग विथ माय ओन फ्लो
एंड ये फ्लो वैसे ही रहेगा। कई लोग कई
सारे मैसेज करते हैं कि भैया प्रैक्टिकल
ला दो। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सर
प्रैक्टिकल ला दो। सर हम बिना प्रैक्टिकल
के हमसे रहा नहीं जा रहा है। तो मैं उनसे
यही बोलता हूं कि वो तो कभी नहीं हो सकता
है कि मैं आपके कहने पे प्रैक्टिकल ला दूं
या आपके कहने पे मैं अपना पूरा का पूरा
लॉजिक या पूरा का पूरा फ्लो चेंज कर दूं।
चेंज कभी नहीं होगा। वो मेरे अकॉर्डिंग ही
चलेगा क्योंकि मैं आपसे बेटर जानता हूं कि
मैं कैसे पढ़ा सकता हूं या मैं कैसे आपको
बताऊंगा कि आपके लिए बेस्ट होगा। एंड तभी
आप उसको सीख रहे हैं। मैं आपको सिखा रहा
हूं। तो आपको उसी फ्लो में जाना है। मैं
बस इतना ही बोलूंगा। कुछ चीजें आपको हो
सकती है उतनी कुछ खास पसंद ना आए। बट
स्टिल आपको अगर उस फ्लो में जाना है तो
आपके लिए वो बेस्ट रहेंगे आगे चलके। मैं
इस बात की गारंटी आपको देता हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब आज की जो क्लासेस हैं हम उसमें ओएसआई
और टीसीपीआईपी मॉडल्स को समझने वाले हैं।
उसको जानने वाले हैं। एंड बहुत ही लेमैन
लैंग्वेज में बहुत ही सिंपल एंड बहुत ही
इजी लैंग्वेज में समझेंगे ताकि आपको ये
मॉडल्स समझ में आ जाए क्योंकि नेटवर्किंग
में सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट ये मॉडल्स होते हैं
और भी पार्ट्स हैं। हालांकि बट उन सबका
इसके बिना कोई मतलब नहीं बनता है। पूरी
इंटरनेट ओएसआई टीसीपीआईपी मॉडल पे ही काम
करती है। मोर स्पेसिफिकली बोले तो इन
प्रैक्टिकल टीसीपीआईपी मॉडल पे काम करती
है। बट ओएसआई मॉडल्स भी जो है वो आपके
कंसेप्ट्स के लिए बहुत जरूरी है। क्योंकि
इसी पे बेस्ड आपका TCPआईपी मॉडल एंड दोनों
सिमिलर काइंड ऑफ़ मॉडल्स होते हैं। बट
उसमें से कुछ लेयर्स जो है उस पे पूरी
इंटरनेट आपकी एक्टिव होती है। काम करती है
एंड सब एक दूसरे से रिलेटेड है। अब कैसे
हैं रिलेटेड? क्या है? क्या करते हैं
एक्सैक्ट्ली? हम सब जानेंगे और आपको बहुत
मजा आने वाला है। आज तक आपने टीसीपी आईपी
या ओएसआई की ऐसी क्लासेस शायद आपको कहीं
नहीं मिली होगी जो जो बहुत शॉर्ट में बट
बहुत कांसेप्ट के साथ एंड बहुत ही इजी
लैंग्वेज में समझा दें। तो सभी लोग एक बार
मुझे बता दीजिए। आर यू गाइस रेडी फॉर दिस
अमेजिंग एंड शानदार सेशन? लेट मी नो। सभी
रेडी?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके।
यस सर। क्या बात है।
बिल्कुल ओएसआई मॉडल अच्छे से समझाना सर
बहुत प्रॉब्लम्स आती है। बिल्कुल टेंशन मत
लीजिए। अ बहुत अच्छे से समझाऊंगा। बिल्कुल
उसकी बेफिक्र रहिए आप।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[हंसी]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
या [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। सो काफी लोगों ने बोल दिया यस सर
रेडी है। तो चलिए आज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] के इस धमाकेदार
सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। सबसे पहले
ओएसआई मॉडल क्या होता है? उसको समझते हैं।
ठीक है? देखो ओएसआई का फुल फॉर्म सिंपल सा
है ओपन सिस्टम्स इंटरकनेक्शंस। ठीक है?
ओपन सिस्टम्स इंटरकनेक्शंस। सिस्टम्स का
इंटरकनेक्शंस उस मॉडल को डील करता है
ओएसआई मॉडल। दैट्स इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो व्हाट इज दिस? इट इज़ अ सेवन लेयर
फ्रेमवर्क दैट एक्सप्लेंस हाउ डेटा
ट्रेवल्स फ्रॉम वन सिस्टम टू अनदर। ये
सेवन लेयर का क्या है? एक फ्रेमवर्क है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] दैट्स इट। ये
सेवन लेयर का एक फ्रेमवर्क है जिस जो आपको
बताता है कि डेटा कैसे ट्रैवल करती है वन
सिस्टम से अनदर सिस्टम में। बस सिंपल और
कुछ भी नहीं। यानी कि एक डाटा की जर्नी को
यह एक्सप्लेन करती है। इतना ही आपको समझना
है। किसी को भी कोई पूछे इतना ही आपको
बोलना है। व्हाट इज ओएसआई मॉडल? तो भैया
ओएसआई मॉडल इज अ एक फुल फॉर्म बोल देना
अगर ज्यादा हो तो। हालांकि फुल फॉर्म
बोलने से कोई फायदा या फर्क नहीं पड़ता है
ज्यादा। ओएसआई मॉडल स्टैंड्स फॉर ओपन
सिस्टम इंटरकनेक्शंस। एंड दिस इज अ सेवन
लेयर फ्रेमवर्क दैट बेसिकली टेल्स द जर्नी
ऑफ ए डाटा एंड हाउ
लाइक हाउ इट ट्रेवल्स फ्रॉम वन सिस्टम टू
अनदर सिस्टम। दैट्स इट। यह आप इसको एज अ
टेक्निकली ऐसे बोल सकते हैं। बहुत अच्छा
ये एक एक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डेफिनेशन हो सकता है। डेफिनेशंस को
अलग-अलग तरीकों से बोला जा सकता है। बट जब
आपको कोई चीज डिफाइन करना हो और इंटरव्यू
के लिए आप प्रिपेयर करके जाए। तो बहुत लोग
ना बहुत लाइटली जाते हैं इंटरव्यू के लिए
प्रिपेयर करके। मतलब एसओसीएल वन के लिए भी
इंटरव्यू देने जा रहे हैं। इंटरव्यू के
लिए मान लो सिलेक्ट हो गए। उनका कॉल आ गया
है जाना है उनको या ऑनलाइन इंटरव्यू दे
रहे हैं मीट कर रहे हैं कुछ भी तो वो बहुत
कैजुअल उसकी प्रिपरेशन करते हैं। उनको
लगता है ना क्या है? सामने वाले जो पूछेगा
जवाब देना है। आपको अपना इंप्रेशन वही तो
डालना है। फर्स्ट इंप्रेशन इज द लास्ट
इंप्रेशन। वो इंप्रेशन डालने के लिए आपको
टेक्निकिटी को इंक्लूड करना है। आपकी
स्पोकन थोड़ी सही होनी चाहिए। नहीं देखो
वैसे स्पोकन में कुछ गड़बड़ भी है। थोड़ा
बहुत ऊपर नीचे चलता है इंटरव्यू में। मगर
सामने वाला इंटरव्यूअर इतनी टैल इतना
टैलेंटेड होगा, इतना समझदार होगा तो वो
उसको तो इग्नोर कर देगा। बट टेक्निकिटी जो
है वो इग्नोर नहीं की जा सकती है। कोई भी
इंटरव्यूअर नहीं करेगा। तो टेक्निकल
पॉइंट्स को टेक्निकल चीजों को घुसाना है
हर चीज में। सिंपल।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] तो ये
ओएसआई मॉडल होता है जो कि सेवन लेयर का एक
फ्रेमवर्क है जो सिर्फ जर्नी डेटा की
जर्नी को बताता है कि वो एक सिस्टम से
दूसरे सिस्टम में किस तरीके से ट्रैवल कर
रही है। बस पूरा ओएसआई यही है ओएसआई। अब
ओएसआई का मतलब समझ में आ गया। एक बंदा बोल
रहा था अभी एक ने किसी ने बोला अभी चैट
में कि सर ओएसआई क्या है? वो समझ में बहुत
दिक्कत होती है। कंफ्यूजन होता है। मुझे
लगता है ओएसआई की डेफिनेशन आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा। राइट?
गॉट इट
एवरीवन गॉट इट
या करेक्ट दिस इज़ थ्योरेटिकल मॉडल
प्रैक्टिकल हम टीसीपीआईपी पे आएंगे टीसीपी
पे जब आएंगे टीसीपीआईपी पे तो हम उसको बाद
में देखेंगे तो थ्योरेटिकल मॉडल है क्या
है वो सब अभी छोड़ दीजिए बस अभी
कांसेप्ट्स को गेन कीजिए बस बात खत्म ठीक
है गॉट इट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके
या करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट इंटरव्यूज आपके
मोस्टली जो है इंग्लिश में ही होते हैं बट
अगर कभी किसी का लैंग्वेज इशू हो गया कई
बार ऐसा होता है कभी किसी का कुछ इशू आ
रहा है तो वो कंफर्टेबल होते हैं बट
टेक्निकिटी को नहीं छोड़ सकते वो तो अब
ओएसआई जो मॉडल होती है आपकी गाइस देखो
ओएसआई जो मॉडल होती है उसमें सात लेयर्स
होते हैं। अब यह जो लेयर्स हैं वह दो
तरीके से काम करते हैं। वह मैं आपको आगे
बताऊंगा। उसमें एक इनकैप्सुलेशन होता है,
डीकैप्सुलेशन होता है, डाउनवर्ड एंड
अपवर्ड दो चीजें होती हैं। वो मैं अभी बाद
में डिस्कस करूंगा। फिलहाल हम इन लेयर्स
को पहले देखते हैं। सो अगर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम वन से
स्टार्ट करते हैं तो हमारा जो अ बेस है वो
उसमें पहले नंबर पे फिजिकल लेयर जो होती
है वो आती है। दूसरे पे डेटा लिंक आता है।
तीसरे पे नेटवर्क लेयर आता है। चौथे पे
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर आता है। पांचवें पे सेशन
लेयर आता है। छठे पे प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर आता
है। सातवें पे एप्लीकेशन लेयर आता है। ये
डायग्राम से आप समझ रहे होंगे। कौन सा
लेयर किस चीज को डिनोट करता है? फिजिकल
में केबल्स वगैरह की आप देख सकते हैं।
डेटा लिंक में आप वायरलेस सिस्टम्स एंड जो
भी नेट सिग्नल्स वगैरह डेटा का वो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देख सकते हैं।
इसमें नेटवर्क आईपी वगैरह को देख सकते
हैं। ट्रांसपोर्ट में आप टीसीp एंड
ट्रांसपोर्टेशन ऑफ़ डेटा ये सब देख सकते
हैं। सेशन में आप सेशंस लॉगिनस एक्टिविटीज
ये सब देख सकते हैं। प्रेजेंटेशन एंड
एप्लीकेशन इन दोनों में ये दोनों यूज़र्स
के सबसे ज्यादा नजदीक लेयर्स होते हैं। जो
यूज़र्स सेंट्रिक होते हैं और यूज़र्स के
सबसे पास के लेयर्स होते हैं। जहां पे
यूजर इंटरेक्शन सबसे ज्यादा होता है।
बेसिकली जो एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं जो भी
काम आप में लेते हैं आप किसी भी तरह का
कोई भी जो एप्लीकेशन आप यूज़ करते हैं वो आ
जाते हैं। अब यहां पे इन चीजों को थोड़ा
सा जब समझेंगे डिटेल में तो और भी ज्यादा
क्लेरिटी मिलेगी। तो सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं। बट इसको हम एक बार एग्जांपल के
थ्रू भी समझते हैं कि किस तरीके की चीजें
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे होती है।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
अब देखो यहां पे यूजर साइड यहां पे ये जो
लेयर्स हैं ये जो आपके लेयर्स हैं ये ये
यूजर्स से थोड़े दूर होते हैं। यहां पे ये
ट्रांसपोर्टेशन का लेयर होता है। यहां पे
ये सेशन होता है। यहां से यूजर इंटरेक्शन
शुरू हो जाती हैं। एंड सेशन प्रेजेंटेशन
एप्लीकेशन पे यूजर इंटरेक्टेड थिंग्स होती
हैं। एग्जीक्यूट होती हैं। राइट? चाहे वो
किसी तरह का सेशन की बात हो, चाहे किसी
तरह के क्रिप्टोग्राफिक एल्गोरिदम्स की
बात हो, किसी तरह का सिक्योरिटी का बात हो
या एप्लीकेशन यूज़ करने की बात हो या कुछ
भी बात हो, एवरीथिंग हैपेंस इन दिस काइंड
ऑफ़ लेयर्स। अब हम इसको एक-एक चीज़ करके
थोड़ा समझते हैं लेयर वाइज़ लेयर वाइज़। तो
देखो, यूजुअली यहां पे हम सेवंथ नंबर से
स्टार्ट करते हैं एप्लीकेशन लेयर से। फिर
प्रेजेंटेशन, फिर सेशन, फिर ट्रांसपोर्ट
यह सब पर जाएंगे। एप्लीकेशन लेयर में
एग्जांपल के तौर पर हम देखें तो जो हमारे
प्रोटोकॉल्स वगैरह होते हैं वो इसमें आप
कंसीडर कर सकते हैं। लाइक एसडीपी हो गया,
एफटीपी हो गया। ठीक है? एसएमटीपी हो गई।
दीज़ आर इंक्लूडेड इन द एप्लीकेशन लेयर।
नाउ हियर रिगार्डिंग प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर वी
टॉक अबाउट डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ इंटीग्रिटी
एंड डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स लाइक
इंक्रिप्शन एंड ऑल। उसके बाद सेशंस में
सेशन मैनेजमेंट के बारे में हम बात करते
हैं। लाइक इसमें हम कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को
बोल सकते हैं मोस्टली प्रेजेंटेशन में।
सेशन में हम सेशन मैनेजमेंट के बारे में
बात करते हैं। मैं एक-एक करके सारी लेयर्स
को भी डिस्कस करूंगा। तो बिल्कुल बेफिक्र
रहना है। एकदम ध्यान को केंद्रित करके
रखना है आपको आज के सेशन पे। सेशन में
सेशन मैनेजमेंट्स की बात करते हैं। लॉगिनस
की बात करते हैं। यूजर्स के सेशंस के बारे
में बात करते हैं। ट्रांसपोर्ट में हम
एक्चुअल जो ट्रांसपोर्टेशन होती है डेटा
की टीसीp यूडीपी जिसके बारे में मैंने
ऑलरेडी बताया है। ट्रांसमिशन कंट्रोल
प्रोटोकॉल एंड यूजर डाटा ग्राम प्रोटोकॉल
के बारे में बात करते हैं। नेटवर्क में हम
IP एड्रेसेस एंड ऑल के बारे में बात करते
हैं। डेटा लिंक में हम मैक के बारे में
बात करते हैं। एंड फिजिकल में हम फिजिकल
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डिवाइसेस एंड जो
रियल मशीनंस या केबल्स या जो भी फिजिकल
चीजें होती हैं उसके बारे में हम डील करते
हैं। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये सात
लेयर्स हैं। ठीक है? अब यहां पे हम एक-एक
लेयर्स को स्टार्ट करते हैं। डिस्कस करते
हैं एंड क्या करते हैं वो देखते हैं।
एसओसी का पर्सपेक्टिव देखते हैं। सारी चीज
देखते हैं। तो हम स्टार्ट करेंगे सातवें
नंबर से। तो हम यहां पे नीचे से ऊपर नहीं
जा रहे हैं। बेसिकली हम यहां पे 7 टू वन
की तरफ जा रहे हैं। वो भी मैं बताऊंगा
क्या है, कैसे है, क्या चीजें हैं वो सब
चीजें हम करेंगे। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एप्लीकेशन
लेयर को हम थोड़ा समझते हैं। अब याद
रखिएगा थोड़ा सा आप लोगों को मैं एक
रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा कि प्लीज आप लोग जो है अ
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट कि इस पे थोड़ा सा थोड़ा
सा ध्यान दीजिएगा। राइट? थोड़ा सा इस पे
ध्यान दीजिएगा। नहीं
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] प्रेजेंटेशन
लेयर यूज़्ड फॉर डाटा कंप्रेशन। ठीक है? बट
इट्स नॉट नीडेड कि सिर्फ डाटा कंप्रेशन
होती है। देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट इज़
हैपनिंग इन प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर। हम उसके
बारे में डिस्कस उसके बारे में भी डिस्कस
करेंगे। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] द एप्लीकेशन
लेयर इज़ द टॉप मोस्ट लेयर ऑफ द ओएसआई मॉडल
एंड इज़ द क्लोजेस्ट टू द एंड यूजर। जो
एप्लीकेशन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लेयर है वो सबसे टॉप का लेयर होता है
ओएसआई मॉडल में। एंड सबसे क्लोज जो एंड
यूजर का होता है जैसे मैंने पहले ही बोला
वो आपका एप्लीकेशन लेयर होता है। दिस लेयर
प्रोवाइड्स द इंटरफ़ेस फॉर यूज़र्स एंड
सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशनेशंस टू इंटरेक्ट विद
द नेटवर्क। सिंपल। तो ये लेयर क्या करता
है? ये एक इंटरफ़ेस प्रोवाइड करता है।
किसको? यूज़र्स एंड एप्लीकेशनेशंस को। मतलब
एक लेयर है। ठीक है? एक मॉडल है। उसमें एक
सात लेयर्स हैं। सातवें में सबसे सातवां
जो नंबर लेयर है एप्लीकेशन वो यूजर के
सबसे पास में रहता है। तो उसका काम क्या
होता है? एक इंटरफ़ेस प्रोवाइड करना। किसके
लिए? यूज़र्स को भी। और जो सॉफ्टवेयर
यूज़र्स यूज़ कर रहा है, उसको भी। जैसे मैं
अगर सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहा हूं। ठीक है? सॉरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
मैं एक सिस्टम यूज़ करूं तो मैं एक यूजर
हूं। मैं एक एप्लीकेशन मान लो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यूज़ कर रहा हूं।
मैं मान लो ईमेल Gmail एप्लीकेशन यूज़ कर
रहा हूं। तो मैं एक एप्लीकेशन यूज़ कर रहा
हूं। अब वो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नेटवर्क से इंटरेक्ट करेगा तो उसका
इंटरफ़ेस प्रोवाइड करता है हमारा
एप्लीकेशन। हैं। इट हैंडल्स हाई लेवल
फंक्शनंस लाइक फाइल ट्रांसफरर्स, ईमेल्स
एंड वेब ब्राउजिंग। तो जो भी आप फाइल्स
ट्रांसफर्स [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] करते
हैं, जो भी आप वेब ब्राउजिंग करते हैं, जो
भी आप ईमेल्स का ईमेल्स वाली चीजें करते
हैं, वो सब एप्लीकेशन लेयर हैंडल करता है।
दैट्स व्हाई एप्लीकेशन लेयर इज़ द
क्लोजेस्ट टू यूजर एंड सबसे ज्यादा यूजर
सेंट्रिक लेयर कहा जाता है। तो बेसिकली
यूजर इंटरेक्ट करते हैं यहां पे। एग्जांपल
में आपका वेब ब्राउजिंग, ईमेल, फाइल
ट्रांसफर ये सब होते हैं। प्रोटोकॉल्स आर
डिफरेंट दैट कैन बी यूज्ड एचटीp, एसटीpएस,
एफटीपी, एसएमटीपी ये सब प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं
जो यूज़ में लिए जाते हैं। एज एसओसी एल1
आपका पर्सपेक्टिव क्या हो सकता है कि यहां
पे फिशिंग अटैक्स हो सकते हैं। मशियस
यूआरएल्स जो है क्राफ्ट किए जा सकते हैं।
सस्िशियस एपीआई कॉल्स जो हैं वो
कॉल किए जा सकते। सक्सेसफुली एपीआई कॉल्स
देखने को आपको मिल सकते हैं। तो ये आपका
एज अ एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव है इस लेयर को
लेकर एप्लीकेशन को लेकर के क्योंकि यहां
पे क्या हो रही है? में ब्राउजिंग हो रही
है। ट्रांसफर फाइल ट्रांसफर हो ईमेल
हैंडलिंग हो रही है। सब चीज़ हो रहा है। तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है फेसिंग अटैक ईमेल के
थ्रू हो सकता है। मेलिशियस यूआरएल जो है
इंजेक्ट किए जा सकते हैं। ब्राउज़र्स के
थ्रू आपको विजिट कराया जा सकता है। सस्पिस
एपीआई कॉल्स जो है फाइल ट्रांसफर्स की हम
जब बात करें या किसी भी तरह का डेटा आपको
लेने की बात करें तो वहां पे सस्िशियस
फाइल ट्रांस एपीआई कॉल्स होने के भी
चांसेस हो सकते हैं। सो ये एप्लीकेशन लेयर
था। आई होप आपको एप्लीकेशन लेयर समझ में
एटलीस्ट आया होगा। पहले मुझे कंफर्म कीजिए
देन आई विल मूव फॉरवर्ड। लेट मी नो
एवरीबॉडी इन द कमेंट्स प्लीज।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बिल्कुल सही आदित्य सिंह बिल्कुल सही। कोई
बात नहीं नमन। अभी जस्ट हमने स्टार्ट ही
किया है। थोड़ा सा स्टार्टिंग पार्ट अगर रह
भी गया होगा तो कर्सर को वो थोड़ा पहले ले
जा के भी देख सकते हो आप। अंडरस्टुड?
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एवरीथिंग
गॉट इन माइंड गाइस सभी समझ में आ गया? सभी
का मन में आ गया। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब आ जाते हैं [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर में। ठीक है?
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर में आ जाते हैं। देखो
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर का क्या काम है? जो कि
छठा लेयर होता है। द प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर इज़
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर द ट्रांसलेशन, इंक्रिप्शन
एंड कंप्रेशन ऑफ़ डेटा। तो अभी एक अह कोई
बोल रहा था कि सर इट इज़ मेनली यूज़्ड फॉर
कंप्रेशन ऑफ़ डेटा। बिल्कुल सही है।
कंप्रेशन ऑफ़ डेटा के लिए यूज़ में लिया तो
जरूर जाता है। बट इसके और भी अह फंडामेंटल
वर्किंग्स हैं जिसमें आप ट्रांसलेशंस को
भी इंक्लूड कर सकते हैं। इंक्रिप्शंस
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक एल्गोरििदम का यूज़ करना,
इंक्रिप्शनंस करना यानी कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी
को मेंटेन करना इन सब का भी काम होता है
बाय द प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर। ठीक है? ये भी
यूजर सेंट्रिक लेयर है। मतलब यूजर के पास
का लेयर है। तो यूजर इंटरेक्टिव लेयर भी
हो गया। क्योंकि कंप्रेशन जो इंक्रिप्शन
जो है वो ऑब्वियस सी बात है यूजर से
रिलेटेड है। डेटा यूजर से रिलेटेड हर चीज़
यूजर से रिलेटेड है ही। तो जस्ट एप्ली
आपका जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर है उसके जस्ट नीचे
आपका प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर है। सेवंथ के नीचे
सिक्स्थ वाला ये लेयर है। इट एनश्योर्स
दैट द डेटा सेंट फ्रॉम एप्लीकेशन लेयर इज़
इन अ फॉर्मेट दैट कैन बी अंडरस्टुड बाय द
रिसीविंग सिस्टम। बस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मतलब जो डेटा
सेंड की जा रही है एप्लीकेशन लेयर की तरफ
से। मान लो कि मैंने ईमेल यूज़ किया, मैं
वेब ब्राउज़र यूज़ कर रहा हूं या जो भी डाटा
सेंड कर रहा हूं। ठीक है? तो उसको ऐसा
मतलब कि इंश्योर करना कि वो इस तरीके का
फॉर्मेट में हो कि रिसीवर उसको प्रॉपर्ली
समझ पाए। दैट्स द मेन थिंग। कि रिसीवर
उसको प्रॉपर्ली समझ पाए। रिसीवर जो सिस्टम
होता है। बस इसका काम यही होता है। इट
इंश्योरर्स द डेटा सेंड फ्रॉम एप्लीकेशन
लेयर इज़ इन अ फॉर्मेट। ऐसा फॉर्मेट में हो
जो कि रिसीविंग सिस्टम को समझ में आ जाए।
दिस लेयर ऑफेन हैंडल्स टास्क लाइक डेटा
फॉर्मेटिंग, कररेक्टर इनकोडिंग, डेटा
प्रिंशन या फॉर्मेटिंग में अलग-अलग तरह की
चीजें होती हैं। डिक्रिप्शन सब कुछ करता
है ये काम। तो ये है प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर का
काम। अब इसमें वही मैंने यहां पे मेंशन
किया है। डेटा फॉर्मेटिंग का काम है। इसका
ट्रांसलेशन का काम है। इंक्रिप्शन
डिक्रिप्शन का काम है। ये सब प्रेजेंटेशन
लेयर में आपके होते हैं। एग्जांपल में
आपके एसएसएल, टीएलएस ये सब इसी के
एग्जांपल है। इंकोडिंग्स वगैरह इसी के
एग्जांपल हैं। अगर हम एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव
की बात करें तो इंक्रिप्शन को एनालाइज
करना, इंक्रिप्शन को स्टडी करना, एनाल
अच्छे से डील करना, एसएसएल स्ट्रिपिंग
वगैरह ये सब जो है बेसिकली क्या हो सकती
है? एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव के तौर एसओसी के
तौर पे आप एज अ सोच सकते हो कि एज अ
इंक्रिप्शन है तो उनको एनालाइज कीजिए भाई
किस तरह का क्या है कैसे है अगर आप बात
करते हैं डेटा की यहां पे तो उसको आप
देखिए कि कहीं कोई एसएसएल स्ट्रोपिंग या
कुछ ऐसा यूज़ करके या मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक
करके उस डेटा की
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को तो प्रॉब्लमेटिक जोन
में नहीं डाल रहा या कुछ ऐसा कुछ इशू तो
नहीं हो रही राइट? क्योंकि इसका काम ही है
कि उस फॉर्मेट में डेटा को पहुंचाना या उस
फॉर्मेट में डेटा को चेक करना, इंश्योर
करना कि रिसीविंग सिस्टम जो है उसको समझ
में आ जाए बेसिकली कि भैया ये सही है। मैं
समझ सकता हूं। दैट्स इट। तो ये एसएसयू का
एक पर्सपेक्टिव हो सकता है प्रेजेंटेशन
लेयर का। तो बस इतना ध्यान रखना है कि
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर क्या होता है एंड
बेसिकली ये किस चीज के लिए रिस्पांसिबल
होता है। अब इन चीजों को आपको थोड़ा सा
रटना पड़ता है। अब कई लेयर्स हैं, कई
चीजें हैं तो हो सकता है आपको ऐसे याद आए।
बट जब भी आप प्रैक्टिस में रहोगे ना एक
चीज को बार-बार बार-बार बार-बार उसको डील
करोगे, बार-बार एक चीज को ही रिपीट करोगे
तो आपके दिमाग में वो छप जाएगा। तो आपके
दिमाग में ये भी छप जाएगा कि एप्लीकेशन
लेयर में क्या होती है भैया? तो जो भी
ब्राउजिंग ईमेल ऐसे दिमाग में रखना है।
अरे यार ब्राउजिंग जो ईमेल एंड ये सब फाइल
ट्रांसफर करता हूं। ये तो एप्लीकेशन हो
जाएगा पार्ट। फिर जब ये फाइल ट्रांसफर
ब्राउजिंग ये सब कर रहा हूं तो वहां डेटा
की बात हुई है। तो अब डेटा की फॉर्मेटिंग
की बात हो इंक्रिप्शन डिक्रिप्शन इन सब की
बात हो तो भैया हमारा प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
है। अब यहां पे आता है स्टेशन लेयर। तो जब
डेटा चल चुकी है, डेटा ऑलरेडी प्रोसेस हो
चुकी है। जब डेटा पे सारे इंक्रिप्शन
डिक्रिप्शन जो भी इंक्रिप्शन वगैरह जो भी
सिक्योरिटी या जो भी व्हाटएवर यहां पे
फॉर्मेटिंग हो रहे हैं या अनकोडिंग वगैरह
हो रही है ये सब चीज हो चुकी है। तो अब
कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है मान लो तो सेशन
लेयर की बात हम करेंगे। सेशन लेयर
एस्टैब्लिशज़ मैनेजेस एंड टर्मिनेट्स सेशंस
बिटवीन टू कम्युनिकेटिंग डिवाइसेस। सिंपल।
तो अगर दो कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है मतलब एक
कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है दो डिवाइसेस के बीच
में तो हमारा जो सेशन लेयर है वो क्या
करता है वो एस्टैब्लिश मैनेज और टर्मिनेट
करता है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
सेशन लेयर क्या करता है वो उन कम्युनिकेशन
को एस्टैब्लिश करता है मैनेज करता है और
टर्मिनेट करता है। ये सेशन लेयर का काम
है। सेशन लेयर का ये कि अगर दो एक क्लाइंट
सर्वर बीच में बात करें, एक क्लाइंट सर्वर
आपस में बात कर रहे हैं या दो कंप्यूटर
सर्वर्स बात कर रहे हैं तो द मेन वर्क ऑफ़
सेशन लेयर इज़ टू एस्टैब्लिश
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] द एस्टैब्लिश द
कनेक्शन सेशंस मैनेज द सेशंस एंड टर्मिनेट
द सेशंस। ठीक है? इट इंश्योर दैट डेटा
एक्सचेंज इज़ सिंक्रोनाइज़्ड एंड अलाउज़
एप्लीकेशनेशंस टू कम्युनिकेट इफेक्टिवली
विदाउट इंटरफेरेंसेस।
इसका काम होता है ये इंश्योर करना
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कि डेटा की जो
एक्सचेंज हो रही है वो प्रॉपर
सिंक्रोनाइज्ड हो। सब कुछ प्रॉपर हो,
अच्छे से हो। एंड एप्लीकेशनेशंस को अलाउ
करती है कि ये एक दूसरे से कम्युनिकेट
करें बिना किसी प्रॉब्लम, बिना किसी
इंटरफेरेंस के। मतलब
दो एप्लीकेशंस हैं। दोनों एप्लीकेशनेशंस
एक दूसरे से बात करें, बिना किसी टेंशन
के, बिना किसी दिक्कत के और आराम से
कम्युनिकेशन चलती जाए। यह सेशन लेयर का
मेन मोटिव है। एंड यही यह एनश्योर करता
है। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अगेन व्हाट
इट डज़ मेंटेन सेशन बिटवीन सिस्टम्स।
एग्जांपल क्या है? लॉग इन सेशंस हो गए
हैं। सेशंस कुकीज़ हो गए हैं या जो भी सेशन
एंड लॉग इन से रिलेटेड चीजें हैं वो सब
काम सेशन लेयर करता है। तो ये भी अब दिमाग
में रख लेना है आपको कि सेशन का मतलब
सेशन। दो एक यूजर का करंट जो भी उसका अभी
स्टेट होता है लॉग इन करने के बाद वह सेशन
तो सेशंस लॉगिनस ये सब जो है ये सेशन लेयर
में डील होती है एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव यहां
पे क्या है सेशन हाईजैकिंग एंड टोकन रीयूज
उसको एज अ एज अ एसओसी एल1 आपको किन बातों
का ध्यान रखना है कि भैया किसी तरह की
सेशन हाईजैकिंग की प्रोबेबिलिटी है कोई या
टोकन रीयूज की प्रोबेबिलिटी है सेशन टोकंस
की बात हो या किसी भी तरह का कोई
सिक्योरिटी टोकंस की बात हो तो उसका कोई
रीयूज़ यूज़ तो नहीं हो रहा? कोई मैिशियस
यूज़ तो नहीं हो रहा? सेशन हजकिंग टाइप
जैसी कोई अटैक्स या कोई चीज हो तो नहीं
रही है। तो ये एज अ एसोसिएल वन आपका
पर्सपेक्टिव होना चाहिए। सो दिस वाज़ ऑल
अबाउट सेशन लेयर। सेशन लेयर आप लोगों को
समझ में आया? बता दीजिए एक बार। डिड यू
गेट डिड यू अंडरस्टैंड अबाउट सेशन लेयर
गाइस? बताइए मुझे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या या सो टोकंस गेट एक्सपायर्ड एब्सोलुटली
टोकंस एक्सपायर्ड होते हैं। डिपेंड करते
हैं नेचर ऑफ़ टोकन पे। डिपेंड करता है नेचर
ऑफ़ टोकन पे। सम टोकंस मे नॉट एक्सपायर और
सम टोक सम टोकंस व्हिच इज गेटिंग
एक्सपायर्ड मे टेक अ बिट ऑफ टाइम टू गेट
एक्सपायर्ड एंड रीयूज उनको किया जा सकता
है अगर वो रैंडमली इफेक्टिवली चेंज नहीं
हो रहे हैं बार-बार तो ऐसे केसेस में कई
बार टोकंस का रीयूज होता है। दैट्स द मेन
थिंग राइट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो ये था सेशन लेयर।
ओके नाउ द नेक्स्ट इज द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर।
इससे सिंपल सा फंडा समझ में आता है
ट्रांसपोर्ट का काम। मतलब ढोने का काम ये
शायद करता होगा। ये आपको सम ये सुन के
आपको समझना है। द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
इंश्योर द रिलायबल डिलीवरी ऑफ़ डेटा बिटवीन
टू डिवाइसेस अक्रॉस अ नेटवर्क। सिंपल सा
फंडा है कि डेटा की डिलीवरी का जो ठेका ले
रखा है, वह हमारे ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर ने दे
रखा है कि भैया डाटा जो है वह उस उस यहां
पर यह क्या करता है? रिलायबल डिलीवरी ऑफ
डाटा मतलब इंटीग्रिटी, कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी,
अवेलेबिलिटी तीनों चीजें यहां पर हम
बोलेंगे कि फॉलो होनी चाहिए। तभी वह डेटा
सही तरीके से सही
रिसीवर के पास पहुंच सकती है या पहुंच
पाएगी। तो, ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर इंश्योरर्स द
रिलायबल डिलीवरी ऑफ़ डेटा। डेटा की रिलायबल
डिलीवरी इंश्योर करता है बिटवीन टू
डिवाइसेस दो डिवाइसेस के बीच में। इट
सेगमेंट्स द डेटा रिसीव्ड फ्रॉम द अपर
लेयर्स एंड प्रोवाइड्स एरर डिटेक्शन एंड
करेक्शन। अभी किसी ने पूछा था चैट में कि
भैया वो एरर डिटेक्शन और एरर वाली चीज किस
में होती है? तो यहां पे आपके लिए आ चुका
है। देखो पेशेंस के साथ हर चीज आपको मैं
बताऊंगा। हर चीज आएगी। टेंशन बिल्कुल नहीं
लेनी है कि कोई चीज छूट रही है कुछ भी।
जितना इंपॉर्टेंट है एसओसी एल वन के लिए
उससे एक लेवल ऊपर का ही आपको पता चलेगा।
नीचे का शायद आपको नहीं पता चलेगा। एक
लेवल नीचे तो हम कभी नहीं रहेंगे। तो
बेफिक्र होके आप इसको देखते जाइए। इट
सेगमेंट्स द डेटा रिसीव्ड फ्रॉम द अपर
लेयर्स एंड प्रोवाइड्स एरर डिटेक्शन एंड
करेक्शन। सिंपल सा ऊपर वाले लेयर से जो
डिटेक्शन जो भी डेटा आ रही है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
उस पे वो एरर डिटेक्शन एंड करेक्शन को
बेसिकली प्रोवाइड करता है। ठीक है? यह
इसका काम है। एडिशनली इट कंट्रोल्स फ्लो
टू प्रिवेंट कंजेशन एंड गारंटीज़ दैट द
डेटा इज़ डिलीवर्ड इन द करेक्ट ऑर्डर। यह
इस चीज को भी मैनेज करता है कि कंजेशंस ना
हो डेटा डिलीवरी में। अब जैसे ऐसा ना हो
कि एक डेटा अभी आया क्यू में ही है तब तक
दूसरा डेटा भी आ गया। वो भी क्यू में आ
गया। तीसरा डेटा आगे क्यू में आ गया। अब
ऐसा ना हो कि ओवरलैप हो जाए या कुछ ऐसा हो
जाए कि पीछे जो डेटा को जाना चाहिए था वो
आगे जाके पहले पहुंच जाए। तो ये सब चीजों
को भी इंश्योर करना ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का
काम है। मतलब जिस पर्टिकुलर वे में जिस
पर्टिकुलर
ऑर्डर में या जिस पर्टिकुलर ऑर्डर में
डेटा ट्रैवल करके आ रही है उसी ऑर्डर में
रिसीवर तक पहुंचनी चाहिए। उसी ऑर्डर में
जो है जो डेटा है वहां डेस्टिनेशन जिस जो
भी उसका डेस्टिनेशन है वहां तक पहुंचना
चाहिए। ऐसा नहीं जैसे अब कोई एक नंबर पे
आया फिर दो नंबर पे आया फिर तीन नंबर पे
आया फिर चार नंबर पे आया तो पहले एक नंबर
वाला ही पहुंचेगा। फिर दो नंबर को पहुंचना
चाहिए। फिर तीन नंबर को डेस्टिनेशन में
चौथे ऐसे करके तो यह एक करेक्ट ऑर्डर को
भी मेंटेन करता है एंड डेटा जो है वो
करेक्ट ऑर्डर में ही डिलीवर हो रही है।
इसको इंश्योर करता है। कोई कंजेशन नहीं हो
रही हो। किसी तरह का नेटवर्क कंजेशन जिस
तरीके से आप सुनते हैं जानते हैं। तो उस
डेटा में किसी तरह का कोई कंजेशन नहीं हो
रहा हो वो भी यह डील करता है। तो
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर बेसिकली क्या करता है?
डाटा रिलायबली मतलब एक अच्छे तरीके से
करेक्ट वे में एंड विदाउट कंजेशन डाटा
जिसको जानी है जहां जानी है वहां पहुंच
जाए डिलीवर हो जाए बस इसी का जिम्मेदारी
जो है ये ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर उठाता है यही
इसकी प्रॉपर जिम्मेदारी है जिसको ये फॉलो
करता है। अब यहां पे क्या है? एंड टू एंड
कम्युनिकेशन एंड रिलायबिलिटी। सिंपल एंड
टू एंड कम्युनिकेशन एंड रिलायबिलिटी जो दो
चीजें मेनली यह करता है। प्रोटोकॉल्स में
आप टीसीp यूडीपी को रख सकते हैं। ऑब्वियस
सी बात है टीसीपी इज़ रिलायबल। यूडीपी बहुत
फास्ट है बट अनरिलायबल है। अब इसके बारे
में देखो टीसीपी यूडीपी क्या होता है?
इसके बारे में भी हम डिस्कस करेंगे आने
वाले क्लासेस में। ऑब्वियस सी बात है
बिकॉज़ दीज़ आर सम दीज़ आर बिग टॉपिक्स एंड
दीज़ अह नीडेड टू बी अ टॉट इवन फॉर एनी
काइंड ऑफ़ साइबर सिक्योरिटी डोमेन कोई सा
भी डोमेन हो इनके बिना वो डोमेन अधूरे
हैं। ठीक है? तो इस हम डिस्कस करेंगे बट
अगर आप खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर करना चाहें तो
आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। नॉट एन इशू। एज
एन एसओ सीएल वन आपका पर्सपेक्टिव क्या
होना चाहिए? आप पोर्ट स्कैनिंग पे ध्यान
देंगे। सन फ्लड अटैक्स पे ध्यान देंगे।
सस्िशियस स्पोर्ट्स पे ध्यान देंगे। ये सब
चीजें आप एसओसी एल1 की तरह आपको फोकस करके
रखना चाहिए। एसओसी का यह पर्सपेक्टिव होना
चाहिए। ठीक है? जब हम ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर की
बात करें तो ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में सिंपल
सा फंडा मैंने आपको बताया। रिलायबल
डिलीवरी ऑफ़ डेटा होता है यहां पे। जो भी
अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क में जो भी डिवाइसेस हैं
उनके बीच। एंड बेसिकली ये अपर लेयर से जो
डेटा आती है उसमें एरर डिटेक्शन एंड
करेक्शन की बात ये करता है एंड प्रोवाइड
करता है। एंड ये फ्लो ऑफ डेटा को भी
कंट्रोल करता है ताकि कंजेशन ना हो एंड
डेटा जो है करेक्ट ऑर्डर में पहुंच रही हो
डिलीवरी हो रही हो उसकी डेस्टिनेशन पे ये
मेनली असोर करता है। तो आप सब समझ गए
होंगे व्हाट इज़ दिस ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर जो
बहुत ईजीली मैंने आपको बताया है। इतना
ईजीली आपको ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के बारे में
शायद ही आज तक पता चली होगी। चाहे आपने
इंटरनेट या कहीं पे भी कुछ भी करा हो। बट
आई एम श्योर कि आज आपको यह लेयर्स जो मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं वो अच्छे से समझ में आ
रही होगी। आई होप सो राइट। चलिए अब बताइए
मुझे समझ में आ रही है?
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? प्लीज प्लीज एवरीबडी
रिप्लाई मैक्सिमम लोग रिप्लाई कर दीजिए और
लाइक बहुत कम ठोका है आज आपने। तो जो भी
लाइक नहीं ठोके वो लाइक ठोक दीजिएगा ताकि
पता चले। आजकल तो लाइक से ज्यादा कमेंट्स
हो जा रहे हैं। पता नहीं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखो ऑर्डर तो होती है डेटा की देखो ऑर्डर
तो डेटा की होती है ठीक है डेटा की ऑर्डर
होती है अगर ऑर्डर नहीं होगी ना तो आप खुद
सोचो ना आप खुद सोचो जस्ट जस्ट थिंक लाइक
दैट कि अगर कोई डेटा ऑर्डर में नहीं जा
रही है तो सोचो कि एक जो फ्रेम आपको पहले
दिखानी है, वह फ्रेम आपको बाद में दिखा दी
जाएगी। दिस कैन बी पॉसिबल। दिस विल बी
हैपनिंग। राइट? कोई अगर लाइव लाइव कोई चल
रहा है, अभी जैसे मैं लाइव कर रहा हूं।
मान लो मान लो इसमें यूडीपी प्रोटोकॉल यूज़
कर रहा हूं मैं या यूज़ हो रहा है। बाय
चांस मान लो अगर उसमें डेटा का ऑर्डर
मेंटेन नहीं होगा तो क्या होगा? व्हाट विल
हैपन? इट विल नॉट वर्क एट ऑल। ऑब्वियस सी
बात है या किसी भी तरह का जहां पर डाटा का
ऑर्डर की बात हो रही हो तो ऑर्डर में ही
जाना इज द बेटर एंड बेस्ट ऑप्शन एंड वही
चीज होनी चाहिए क्योंकि अगर उसके बिना
डेटा की रिलायबिलिटी नहीं हो सकती है डेटा
जो है वो जो चीजें हमें देखनी है जो चीजें
भेजनी है जो चीजें मिलनी है वो चीज ना
मिलके कुछ भी कुछ और मिल जाएगा राइट दैट्स
द मेन थिंग तो ऑर्डर का यह फंडा है
कोई बात नहीं
नहीं नहीं नहीं देखो
यहां पे प्रोटोकॉल्स जो है वो दोनों आते
हैं टीसीp यूडीपी ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में।
इसका सिंपल सा मतलब यहां पर यह है कि यह
दोनों ही प्रोटोकॉल्स डाटा के डिलीवरी को
लेकर डिनोट करते हैं। डेटा के डिलीवरी के
लिए रिस्पांसिबल होते हैं। ठीक है? अब
इसमें रिलायबल का मतलब सिर्फ यह नहीं होता
है कि [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे अनरिलायबल लिख दिया गया है इसलिए।
इसलिए यह नहीं मतलब होता है कि यह
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का पार्ट नहीं है।
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का पार्ट होने का एक
सिंपल सा फंडा है कि जो डाटा की डिलीवरी
में हेल्प करते वो ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का
पार्ट है। तो वो टीसीपी भी करते हैं,
यूडीपी भी करते हैं। अब यूडीपी का अपना एक
फंडा है। यूडीपी का अपना एक फंडा यह है कि
यहां पे एरर चेकिंग जैसी चीज जो है वह
नहीं होती है। टीसीपी में वह चीज होती है।
वह एक उसका अपना फंक्शनैलिटी है। वह उसकी
अपनी एक चीज है। ड्रॉबैक या जो भी कर सकते
हैं या फास्ट बनाने के लिए उसको इसी तरीके
से बनाया गया है। वो उसका अपना
पर्सपेक्टिव है। बट ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में
ये सेम चीज फॉलो होगी जो मैंने आपको बताया
कि रिलायबल डिलीवरी ऑफ डेटा बिटवीन टू
डिवाइसेस। ये इसमें होती है। इस वजह से जब
हम बात करते हैं एक्चुअल प्रैक्टिकल
कम्युनिकेशन की तो वहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हमारा टीसीपी
आईपी मॉडल ही एक्चुअली यूज़ होता है।
मोस्टली यूज़ होता है। ये बात समझ में आ
रही है सभी को?
और हां मॉडर्न जितने भी कम्युनिकेशंस होते
हैं उसमें टीसीपी यूडीपी दोनों ही यूज़ में
आती है। ये बात याद रखिएगा। ये बात ध्यान
में रखिएगा। जितने भी मॉडर्न कम्युनिकेशंस
हैं फॉर बेटर रिलायबिलिटी एंड डिलीवरी ऑफ़
डेटा टीसीपी एंड यूडीपी बोथ आर बीइंग
यूज़्ड।
आपको क्या लगता है? चलिए मैं आपसे ही पूछ
लेता हूं। आपको क्या लगता है जो हम
YouTube पे लाइव कर रहे हैं। अभी हम लाइव
कर रहे हैं। इसमें आपको क्या लग रहा है?
क्या सिर्फ यूडीपी यूज़ हो रही है या
टीसीपी यूडीपी बोथ आर बीइंग यूज़्ड? मुझे
बताइए आप में से जो भी जिनको भी नॉलेज
होगा या जिनको भी थोड़ा बहुत आईडिया होगा
या गेस कर सकते हैं आप तो आप में से कोई
भी बताइए कि आपको क्या लगता है यूडी जो
अभी मैं लाइव कर रहा हूं YouTube पे या
व्हाटएवर कहीं भी स्ट्रीमिंग के आज के
मॉडर्न कम्युनिकेशन की जब बात करते हैं हम
तो क्या सिर्फ यूडीपी यूज़ होती है या TCP
के साथ यूडीपी यूज़ होती है बताइए मुझे।
लेट मी सी द आंसर्स हियर फर्स्ट
प्लीज आई वांट मैक्सिमम आंसर्स
अ बोथ बोथ तो आप लोग सब ने बोध बोला ऐसे
कैसे
बोध
हां देखो ऑब्वियस सी बात है
ऑब्वियस सी बात देखो टीसीपी एंड यूडीपी
दोनों ही यूज़ होते हैं। कुछ सेक्शन जो है
वह टीसीपी हैंडल करती है बट मोस्टली
यूडीपी यूज़ होता है। जब भी हम बात करते
हैं लाइव चीजों की जब भी हम बात करते हैं
लाइव इंटरेक्शन जहां डेटा जो है उसको
फास्ट पहुंचना है। वहां पे यूडीपी ही यूज़
होती है। अगर वहां टीजीपी भी यूज़ करने लगे
तो वो अलग-अलग तरह के करेक्शंस, एरर
हैंडलिंग ये सब करते-करते वो बहुत टाइम
लगाएगा। वो रियल टाइम में आपको डाटा नहीं
मिल पाएगी। तो क्योंकि हमें डेटा चाहिए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब मैं यहां पे डेटा मैं यहां से बोल रहा
हूं तो मेरी ऑडियो आप तक पहुंच रही है।
मैं यहां पे आपको कैमरे के सामने हूं। तो
मेरी वीडियो आप तक प्रोसेस हो के लाइव
रियल टाइम ऑलमोस्ट रियल टाइम में वो
लेटेंसी का थोड़ा इशू होता है कि जब मैं
बोलूं तो हो सकता है कुछ माइक्रो सेकंड या
कुछ मिलीसे का डि आपको डिफरेंस समझ होता
होगा। हो एंड होता ही है ऑब्वियस सी बात
है बट वो डिफरेंस और भी ज्यादा होती अगर
टीसीp यूज़ हो रही होती तो ऑब्वियस सी बात
है जब हम बात करते हैं विजुअलाइजेशन की जब
हम बात करते हैं यहां पे
ऑडियो की इन सब चीजों में हम मोस्टली
यूडीपी का यूज़ ही करते हैं क्योंकि वो
ज्यादा फास्ट होता है। एक्यूरेसी डजंट
मैटर यहां पे एंड भले बफरिंग हो जाए चलेगा
सब कुछ होगा चलेगा बट एक्यूरेसी एंड
बफरिंग इन ये ज्यादा मैटर नहीं करते मैटर
करते हैं इन दोनों की डिलीवरी जो मैं बोल
रहा हूं और जो मैं वीडियो आपको दिखा रहा
हूं जो वीडियो आ रही है आपके पास वो
प्रॉपर्ली पहुंच जाना चाहिए तो वहां पे
यूडीपी यूज़ होता है। बाकी सारी
कम्युनिकेशंस जो भी चीजें आप करते हैं
YouTube पे बाकी चीजें जैसे कर रहे हैं
वहां पे टीसीपी का यूटिलाइजेशन होता है।
ठीक है? जहां पे ऐसी कोई रियल टाइम में
फास्ट डिलीवरी नहीं चाहिए। दैट्स इट। ये
मेन फंडा है। समझ में आ गया होगा। आई थिंक
ठीक है। चलिए
करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट। निशा चौधरी बिल्कुल
करेक्ट। सही बात है। बिल्कुल अब्सोलुटली
करेक्ट। अब देखिए यहां पे
अब यहां पे एज अ एसओसी आपका पर्सपेक्टिव
क्या होना चाहिए? एज एसओसी एल1 आप पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग के बारे में
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सोच सकते
हैं। सिंस फ्लड अटैक्स के बारे में सोच
सकते हैं। सस्पिशियस पोर्ट्स के बारे में
सोच सकते हैं कि फोर्ट पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
वगैरह कि भैया पोर्ट्स के कुछ इशज़ वगैरह
हो। सिनफड अटैक्स हो सकते हैं जो मैंने
आपको बताया था। सन फ्लड अटैक एंड सस्िशियस
पो्स वगैरह के बारे में आप सोच सकते हैं।
एज अ एसओसी एल1 आपको इन चीजों का ध्यान
रखना है जब हम ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर की बात कर
रहे होते हैं। बस ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का
मतलब बस इतना ही होता है कि डेटा की
डिलीवरी बिटवीन टू डिवाइसेस। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे बाकी भी इसका जो काम है वो भी
मैंने आपको यहां पे समझा दिया कि और ये
किस तरह का काम करता है। एरर एंड
डिटेक्शंस, एरर डिटेक्शन, हैंडलिंग,
करेक्शन ये सब चीजों की भी एंड कंजेशन
वगैरह का जो है वो भी थोड़ा सा ध्यान रखता
है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब हम
बात करते हैं यहां पे थर्ड नंबर ऑफ लेयर
हमारे नेटवर्क [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लेयर की। अब नेटवर्क लेयर जो है यह
रिस्पांसिबल है बेस्ट पाथ चूज़ करने का टू
सेंड डेटा अक्रॉस मल्टीपल नेटवर्क्स। बस
नेटवर्क लेयर का मेन रिस्पांसिबिलिटी इसकी
जो है यही है कि यह बेस्ट पाथ चूज़ करता है
टू सेंड डाटा अक्रॉस मल्टीपल नेटवर्क्स।
मल्टीपल नेटवर्क्स हैं उसमें डेटा सेंड
करना है तो ये क्या करता है कि भैया कौन
सा ऐसा बेस्ट राउट है? कौन सा ऐसा बेस्ट
रूट है या पाथ है उसको चूज़ कर लो। उसी के
थ्रू डेटा को भेजते हैं। ये नेटवर्क लेयर
का काम है। दिस लेयर हैंडल्स लॉजिकल
एड्रेसिंग एंड राउटिंग इनेबलिंग डेटा टू
ट्रेवल फ्रॉम वन नेटवर्क टू अनदर
रिगार्डलेस ऑफ द फिजिकल इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर।
फिजिकल इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर कुछ भी हो डजंट
मैटर। अब ये हैंडल करता है लॉजिकल
एड्रेसिंग एंड राउटिंग। यानी कि जो हम
आईपी एड्रेसिंग या डीएचसीपी या ये सब जो
चीजें हैं जो राउटिंग और ये सब जो काम है
वो सब नेटवर्क लेयर के अंदर में फॉल करता
है। डीएसीपी प्रोटोकॉल एक ऐसा प्रोटोकॉल
जो कि क्या करता है? IP एड्रेस को एलोकेशन
का काम करता है। आईपी एड्रेस एलोकेट करने
का काम करता है एक IPपी पूल से। एंड यहां
पे IPपी एड्रेसिंग का मतलब है मशीनंस को
IP एड्रेस जो है वो असाइन करना कि एक मशीन
को एक IPपी असाइन हो गई। दूसरे को दूसरी
IPपी हो गई। ऐसे करके एंड राउटिंग का काम
जो भी डेटा है उसको रूट करना, राउट करना
या व्हाटएवर ये सारा काम आपका नेटवर्क
क्लियर करता है। तो बढ़िया पाथ चूज़ करना
एंड वहां से डेटा को ट्रैवल कराना एंड
जितने भी आपका एड्रेसिंग लॉजिकल एड्रेसिंग
एंड राउटिंग का काम है वो सब कुछ नेटवर्क
लेयर के अंदर में आता है। क्या करते हैं
भाई? राउटिंग करते हैं। आईपी एड्रेसिंग
होते हैं। साइनिंग ये सब सब कुछ ये काम
करते हैं। आईपी प्रोटोकॉल जो है इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल आईपी वर्जन 4 हो सिक्स हो सब
इसी के अंदर आते हैं। एसओसी एल1 अगर आप
हैं तो आपका आईपी ट्रैकिंग के ऊपर फोकस
रहना चाहिए। Jio लोकेशन के ऊपर सस्िशियस
एक्सटर्नल कनेक्शंस जो है उसके ऊपर फोकस
होना चाहिए कि अगर बाहर से कोई एक्सटर्नल
कनेक्शंस हो रहे हैं या आईपीस वगैरह से
कोई है तो उसको ट्रैक करना हो गया। Jio
लोकेशन के का डिटेल पता करना। Jio किस
तरीके की Jio लोकेशन से इंटरेक्शन हो रही
है या जो भी रिक्वेस्ट्स वगैरह आ रही है
वो सब कुछ आपका एसओसी का पर्सपेक्टिव होना
चाहिए। एसओसी एल1 का पर्सेक्टिव होना
चाहिए। तो ये था आपका नेटवर्क लेयर जिसमें
हमने नेटवर्क लेयर में क्या-क्या चीजें
होती है वो समझी। वो देखी। आई होप आपको ये
भी बहुत क्लियरली समझ में आ गई होगी। तो
मुझे जल्दी से बता दीजिए अगर आपको समझ में
आ गया है तो। प्लीज लेट मी नो।
जल्दी से बताइए। फटाफट बताइए।
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? आर यू गेटिंग?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। चलिए अच्छी बात है।
ओके चलिए अच्छी बात है। काफी लोगों को समझ
में आ गई है। एंड आई होप कि आप सबको
समझ में आता रहे। सर क्या बग बाउंट और
एसओसी को साथ-साथ कर सकते हैं? एसओसी करने
में दिक्कत तो नहीं होगी? नहीं नहीं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं होगी। बिल्कुल आप साथ कर सकते
हैं। रितिक यादव दोनों को साथ में पैरेलली
अगर आपके पास प्रॉपर टाइम है तो बिल्कुल
आप पैरेलली दोनों को कर सकते हैं। नो इशूज़
एट ऑल। अच्छी बात है। अगर दोनों आप साथ
में करते हो तो ये और भी अच्छी बात है। सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] नेटवर्किंग लेयर
इज क्लियर। नाउ वी आर मूविंग टू द सेकंड
लेयर। डेटा लिंक लेयर। हम डेटा लिंक लेयर
की बात करते हैं। अब यहां से आपको समझ में
आ जाना चाहिए। लिंकिंग की बात हो रही है।
लिंकेज की बात हो रही है डेटा की। बस यही
पूरा का पूरा गेम है। द डेटा लिंक लेयर
सीट्स अबव द फिजिकल लेयर। ओके? फिजिकल
लेयर इसके बाद वाली लेयर है। एंड इज़
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर द रिलायबल ट्रांसफर ऑफ़
डेटा अक्रॉस अ फिजिकल नेटवर्क लिंक। मतलब
एक फिजिकल नेटवर्क लिंक है। उस पे डेटा का
जो ट्रांसफर करने का जिम्मेदारी है वह
डाटा लिंक लेयर की होती है। दिस लेयर
इंश्योर द डेटा इज एरर फ्री एंड प्रॉपर्ली
फ्रेम्ड फॉर ट्रांसमिशन। मतलब प्रॉपर्ली
फ्रेम्ड है, एरर फ्री है। एंड फिजिकल
नेटवर्क लिंक के थ्रू ट्रांसफर डेटा जो है
वो हो रही है। इसको इंश्योर करने का काम
डेटा लिंक लेयर करती है। इट आल्सो मैनेजेस
हाउ डिवाइसेस ऑन द सेम लोकल नेटवर्क
कम्युनिकेट विद ईच अदर। यह भी ये मैनेज
करता है कि एक ही
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नेटवर्क में जो डिवाइसेस हैं नेटवर्क पे
वो कैसे एक दूसरे से जो है वो कम्युनिकेट
कर रहे हैं। व्हाट इट डज़ मैक एड्रेस
कम्युनिकेशन लोकल नेटवर्क डिलीवरी लोकल
नेटवर्क डिलीवरी की बात हो किसी डेटा की
या मैक एड्रेसेस बेस्ड कम्युनिकेशन हो मैक
एड्रेस पे बेस्ड कोई कम्युनिकेशन हो रही
हो ये सब इसका इसकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है
एसओसी के पर्सपेक्टिव में होना चाहिए कि
एआरपी स्पूफिंग जैसे अटैक्स को पे ध्यान
दें ऐसा कुछ देखे कि एआरपी स्पूफिंग वगैरह
टाइप तो नहीं हो रही है। मैक एनोमलीज़ यानी
कि मैक एड्रेस में किसी तरह की कोई
गड़बड़ी या कोई कुछ ऐसा कुछ तो नहीं देखने
को मिल रहा है। वह सब चीजें इनका मेन फोकस
इनफोकस पॉइंट होना चाहिए इन डाटा लिंक
लेयर क्योंकि मैक एड्रेसेस कम्युनिकेशन जो
मैक एड्रेस बेस्ड कम्युनिकेशन या फिजिकल
एड्रेस बेस्ड कम्युनिकेशन या हार्डवेयर
एड्रेस बेस्ड कम्युनिकेशन होती है वो इसका
इसकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है लोकल नेटवर्क
डिलीवरीज जो होते हैं लोकल नेटवर्क के
अंदर जो भी किसी भी तरह का डेटा डिलीवरी
या किसी भी तरह का कोई डिलीवरी हो रहा है
नेटवर्क डिली नेटवर्क के अंदर में सेम
लोकल नेटवर्क के अंदर में डेटा की तो वो
इसी के अंदर में आपकी आ जाती है तो सिंपल
सा फंड फंडा है डेटा लिंक लेयर का मतलब
सिंपल सा समझ लेना है कि फिजिकल नेटवर्क
जो लिंक है उसके अक्रॉस सिंपल डेटा का
ट्रांसफर होता है इस डेटा लिंक लेयर के
अंदर में। ठीक है? तो जैसे अब फिजिकल
नेटवर्क में है। अब कोई चीज आप भेज रहे
हो, कोई चीज आप लाइक डेटा को सेंड कर रहे
हो तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है कि वो आपके
सिस्टम से निकल कर जाती है। आपके अलग-अलग
नेटवर्क जो डिवाइसेस हैं उसके थ्रू राउटर
के थ्रू एंटर करती है या बाहर की तरफ जाती
है तो वो डेटा लिंक लेयर का पार्ट होता
है। ठीक है? हां। सेकंड लेयर मैरिज ब्यूरो
बिल्कुल बात है। सेकंड लेयर मैरिज ब्यूरो
जहां पे पोपट लाल हमेशा जाता है। बट
बेचारे का आज तक कुछ नहीं हो पाया। सो वही
है बिल्कुल सही बात है। अब्सोलुटली
करेक्ट।
अच्छा एग्जांपल दिया है।
ओके गाइस। सो [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आई [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] होप आप
समझ पा रहे होंगे।
हम
गाइस आर यू गेटिंग? मैं आज बहुत ज्यादा
जोर से नहीं बोल पा रहा हूं। आई एम नॉट
फीलिंग अ बिट ऑफ गुड टुडे पता नहीं। तो इस
वजह से मैं थोड़ा आराम आराम से आपसे बात
कर रहा हूं। बट आप प्लीज रिस्प्स
रिस्पांस की दीजिए। रिसोंड कीजिए थोड़ा
जल्दी थोड़ा ज्यादा ताकि समझ में आ जाए।
ओके यस सर।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
ठीक है। ओके आई थिंक सबको समझ में आ रहा
है। चलिए
हम ओके। सो लेट्स गो टू द फर्स्ट लेयर।
यहां पे हम बात करते हैं
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] फिजिकल लेयर
की जो हमारे ओएसआई का फर्स्ट लेयर होता
है। हम [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उसके
बारे में बात करते हैं। द फिजिकल लेयर इज़
द लोएस्ट लेयर ऑफ द ओएसआई मॉडल। ये सबसे
लोएस्ट लेयर है आपका। एंड इट डील्स विद द
एक्चुअल ट्रांसमिशन ऑफ़ रॉ बाइनरी डेटा। जो
रॉ यानी मशीन से जो ट्रांसफर डेटा हो रही
है ना मशीनंस के अंदर उसको डील करता है
फिजिकल। रॉ जो बाइनरी डाटा आपकी कंप्यूटर
बाइनरी डाटा को समझती है दैट इज जीरो एंड
वंस तो कंप्यूटर के अंदर जो भी
कम्युनिकेशन जो भी ट्रांसफर जो भी चीजें
होती हैं वो सब जीरोज़ एंड वन में ही होती
है। कंप्यूटर को ए बी सी डी ये ये सब कुछ
पसंद नहीं है ना पता है उसको ज़ीरो वन पता
है। ज़ीरो नो यस वन नो यस नो यस ये सब करता
है। तो ओवर यहां पर काम इसका है इट डील्स
विद द एक्चुअल ट्रांसमिशन ऑफ रॉ बाइनरी
डाटा। 0 वन को हम बाइनरी नंबर्स या बाइनरी
डाटा बोलते हैं। ओवर अ फिजिकल मीडियम।
फिजिकल मीडियम्स के ऊपर जो हो रहा है सच
एज केबल्स, फाइबर ऑप्टिक्स और वायरलेस
सिग्नल्स। तो जो भी फिजिकल मीडियम्स होते
हैं उसके ऊपर जो भी लाइक डील डेटा की
ट्रांसमिशंस की बातें होती हैं वो सब
फिजिकल लेयर के अंदर में आता है। इट
डिफाइन द हार्डवेयर एलिमेंट्स इनवॉल्वड इन
द डेटा ट्रांसफर। इसका काम है हार्डवेयर
एलिमेंट्स को क्या करना? डिफाइन करना। सच
एज नेटवर्क इंटरफसेस जो एनआईसीस होते हैं,
नेटवर्क इंटरफसेस कार्ड्स होते हैं।
केबल्स हो गए, स्विचेस हो गए, इलेक्ट्रिकल
सिग्नल्स यूज्ड टू कैरी द डेटा। वो सारी
चीजें जो हैं वो जो है इनके द्वारा ही
डिनोट की जाती है। फिजिकल लेयर उन सब
चीजों को डिफाइन करता है। जो भी यहां पे
हार्डवेयर एलिमेंट्स हैं, वह डेटा
ट्रांसफर में इनवॉल्व होते हैं। हार्डवेयर
एलिमेंट्स मतलब डेटा ट्रांसफर में जो भी
हार्डवेयर एलिमेंट्स आपके यूज़ होते हैं,
वह सब
फिजिकल ईयर का पार्ट है। एनआईसी भी आपका
उसमें से एक है। केबल्स के थ्रू चीजें
केबल्स के थ्रू ही डाटा का ट्रैवलिंग होता
है। स्विचेस के थ्रू होती है। इलेक्ट्रिकल
सिग्नल्स के फॉर्म में डेटा जो है वो
जाती हैं। तो ये सारी चीजें जो है आपकी
फिजिकल लेयर के पार्ट हैं। राइट? मशीन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लैंग्वेज
बिल्कुल सही बात बोला।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अह
बिलकुल सही बोला। ठीक है? बिलकुल सही बोला
कि मशीन लैंग्वेज की यहां पे हम बात कर
रहे हैं। व्हाट इट डज़? तो हार्डवेयर
ट्रांसमिशंस, इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल्स ये सब
इसका काम है। एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव अगर हम
देखें तो रेयरली रेयरली यूज़ डायरेक्टली
इनका कोई डायरेक्ट यूज़ नहीं होता है
क्योंकि ये फिजिकल लेयर को ही डिनोट करते
हैं। बटेंट इन हार्डवेयर अटैक्स। अगर कोई
हार्डवेयर अटैक्स होते हैं किसी तरह का
उसमें ये काम आ सकते हैं। एसओसीएल वंस का
रोल हो सकता है।
बट यूजुअली यहां पे यहां पे इनका जो यूज़
है डायरेक्ट यूज़ वो रेयर होता है। तो
उसमें ज्यादा आपको टेंशन नहीं लेनी है। तो
ये होता है हमारा फिजिकल लेयर। दिस इज़ नोन
एज फिजिकल लेयर। फिजिकल लेयर आई थिंक आपको
समझ में आ गया होगा। मुझे बता दीजिए एक
बार। फिजिकल लेयर आपको समझ में आ गया क्या
सभी को?
या करेक्ट। हां इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल्स जो
है ना वो आपके केबल्स के अंदर ही होते
हैं। एक फिजिकल चीज के अंदर ही होती है वो
इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल्स। राइट?
आ गया।
ओके।
ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट चलिए अच्छी बात है। कई कई
लोगों को समझ में आ चुकी है। ऑलमोस्ट सबको
आ चुकी है। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके गाइस नाउ हियर कम्स द हाउ डस
कम्युनिकेशन हैपेंस इन ओएसआई मॉडल। अब
इसको मैं थोड़ा सा यहां पे
थोड़ा सा इसको मैं
ऊपर ले जाना चाहूंगा।
हां जी नाउ इट्स डन।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यहां पर हम देखते हैं। नो नो आई एम नॉट
एक्चुअली टायर्ड। एक्चुअली आई एम नॉट
फीलिंग दैट ग्रेट।
अ सोय
थोड़ी सी गड़बड़ लग रही है। इस वजह से मैं
थोड़ा सा शांत हो के आपको बता रहा हूं
चीजों को। बट कोई बात नहीं। अपन समझेंगे।
इस चीज को देखेंगे भी। राइट?
ओके। क्या क्या बोल रहे हो सर? लैपटॉप में
चाय गिर गई है। अच्छा कोई बात नहीं चाय
उठा लो। चाय गिर गई है तो उसको साफ कर लो।
ठीक है। चलिए कोई नहीं अपन इसको कंटिन्यू
करते हैं। हाउ डस अभी क्लासेस लानी भी तो
इंपॉर्टेंट थी क्योंकि आपके 200 कमेंट्स
भी हो गए थे और क्लासेस लानी भी थी। तो
उसको तो कैसे भी लाना है। तो
मैंने सोचा लेकर आते हैं। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या बट स्टिल आई एम नॉट फीलिंग वेल। सो आई
होप कि आप इस चीज पे थोड़ा फोकस करेंगे।
एंड इधर ध्यान देंगे। अभी हाउ डस
कम्युनिकेशन हैपन इन द ओएसआई मॉडल?
कम्युनिकेशन कैसे होती है ओएसआई मॉडल में?
इसको थोड़ा समझते हैं। राइट? चलो मैं
ट्राई करता हूं थोड़ा सा आपको जोश दिलाने
का क्योंकि अभी मैं जोश तो दिला के ही
रहता हूं आपको। बट मैं खुद जब थोड़ा जोश
में कम रहता हूं तो थोड़ी कम आपको दिखती
होगी। बट स्टिल मैं यहां पे ट्राइंग बाकी
जोश की बात नहीं है। बाकी आपको कंटेंट पे
फोकस करना है। आपको टॉपिक्स एंड
कांसेप्ट्स चीजों को फोकस करना है। सीखने
पे फोकस करना है। दैट डजंट नथिंग एल्स
मैटर। राइट?
चलिए
अब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे
कम्युनिकेशन। अब यहां पे देखते हैं। हाउ
डस कम्युनिकेशन कैसे होती है? ओएसआई मॉडल
में? कम्युनिकेशन इन द ओएसआई मॉडल फॉलोज़ अ
सिस्टमैटिक प्रोसेस कॉल्ड इनकैप्सुलेशन
एंड डीकैप्सुलेशन। दो चीजें होती है। एक
इनकैप्सुलेशन होता है, एक डीकैप्सुलेशन
होता है। ये प्रोसेस को फॉलो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] करते हुए
कम्युनिकेशन होती है ओएसआई मॉडल में।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब तीन यहां पे स्टेप्स होते हैं। एक
सेंडर साइड होता है जो प्रोसेस होता है।
एक ट्रांसमिशन जो होती है और एक रिसीवर
साइड का प्रोसेससेस जो होते हैं वह होते
हैं। तो हम [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तीनों को
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अच्छे से समझते हैं। ओके? सो
ओके आई थिंक हम
मैं ट्राई करता हूं इस सेशन को
कंटिन्यू सेशन को अभी कंटिन्यू करने का
क्योंकि आई एम नॉट फीलिंग दैट ग्रेट तो
मुझे नहीं लग रहा शायद मेरे को सेशन एंड
करना पड़ेगा बीच में बट अभी देखते हैं अ
आई विल ट्राई टू फिनिश इट आज ही के आज
क्योंकि फिर वह इसकी दूसरी क्लास लेकर आनी
पड़ेगी।
तो चलिए देखते हैं। सेंडर साइड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इनकैप्सुलेशन एंड डीकैप्सुलेशन जो चीजें
एक दो चीजें होती हैं जिसको फॉलो करता है
ओएसआई के अंदर कम्युनिकेशन आपकी। तो पहले
हम सेंडर साइड को समझते हैं। फिर
ट्रांसमिशन डेटा की समझते हैं। फिर रिसीवर
साइड जो होता है वो। अब सेंडर साइड जो है
वो कुछ भी हो जैसे क्लाइंट जो हो गया जैसे
आप हो गए मान लो आप कोई डाटा रिक्वेस्ट कर
रहे हो। आप अपने ब्राउज़र में कोई वेबसाइट
खोल रहे हो, कोई वेबसाइट विजिट कर रहे हो,
किसी को ईमेल कर रहे हो, व्हाटएवर
कम्युनिकेशन इट। तो आप सेंटर साइड आप एक
क्लाइंट हो गए और रिसीवर साइड आपका सर्वर
जो है वो हो सकता है। राइट? जो आपकी डेटा
को प्रोसेस कर रहा है। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखते हैं सेंटर साइड क्या हो रहा है?
डेटा इज़ जनरेटेड एट द एप्लीकेशन। ओके?
अ डेटा इज जनरेटेड एट द एप्लीकेशन लेयर
एंड मूव्स डाउनवर्ड थ्रू द लेयर्स। डेटा
जो है वो एप्लीकेशन लेयर पे जनरेट होती है
एंड लेयर्स में डाउनवर्ड की तरफ मूव होती
है। तो सबसे ऊपर जो होता है वो एप्लीकेशन
लेयर होता है आपका। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वह आपका एप्लीकेशन लेयर होता है जो यूजर
से सबसे पास में होता है। तो डाटा वहीं पर
जनरेट होती है और वहां से नीचे की तरफ मूव
डाउन करती है डाउनवर्ड्स थ्रू द लेयर्स।
ईच लेयर
ऐड्स इट्स ओन हेडर
एंड समटाइ्स अ फुटर इन कैप्सुलेटिंग द
डेटा विथ लेयर स्पेसिफिक इनेशन। एग्जांपल
एड्रेसिंग, एरर चेकिंग ये सब चीजें होती
है। तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बेसिकली होता क्या है? सेंटर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] के साइड से जब
भी डाटा जनरेट होती है और एप्लीकेशन लेयर
पे और वो नीचे की तरफ मूव करती है। डेटा
जो है जनरेट हो के ऊपर से नीचे की तरफ मूव
करती है। ये पूरा प्रोसेस होता है। बस
इतना समझना है। ऊपर से नीचे की तरफ मूव
होती है। इसका मतलब क्या है यहां पे?
एप्लीकेशन लेयर से प्रेजेंटेशन, सेशन,
ट्रांसपोर्ट, नेटवर्क, डाटा लिंक, फिजिकल
ऐसे होती है। तो हम उसी को समझ रहे हैं।
तो अब हर जो लेयर है वो अपना एक हेडर
डालता है उस डेटा के अंदर में या समटाइ्स
वो फुटर भी एक डाल देता है। बेसिकली उसको
हम इनकैप्सुलेशन बोलते हैं। यानी कि
इनकैप्सुलेट कर देता है डेटा। डेटा को वो
एक तरह से इनकैप्सुलेट का मतलब है इनकोड
करना। आप समझ जाइए एक तरह से इनकैप्सुलेशन
मतलब इनकोड कर दो। डीकैप्सुलेशन मतलब
डिकोड कर दो। मतलब इनकैप्सुलेशन का मतलब
है रैप कर दो, पैक कर दो और डीकैप्सुलेशन
का मतलब है अनरैप कर दो, अनपैक कर दो।
इसका सिंपल फंडा आप यही समझिए। इसी से
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। ठीक है? तो
इनकैप्सुलेशन जब डेटा का करता है तो किस
चीज से रैप करता है? क्या-क्या चीजें? तो
लेयर स्पेसिफिक इनेशन। अब हर लेयर में जो
जो इंफॉर्मेशनेशन उसमें डालनी होती है जो
जो इंफॉर्मेशनेशन आती है उस ले उस
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन जैसे कि एड्रेसिंग अब आईपी
एड्रेसिंग वगैरह हो सकती है। एरर्स
रिलेटेड चीजें हो सकती है। चेकिंग वगैरह
से रिलेटेड चीजें हो सकती हैं। ये सारी
चीजें जो हैं वो आपका होता है सेंडर
साइड्स। ठीक है? अब आती है बात।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। अब बात आती है ट्रांसमिशन की। द
इनकैप्सुलेटेड डेटा नाउ कॉल्ड अ पैकेट। अब
जब डाटा इनकैप्सुलेट हो चुकी है, डाटा में
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन डाल दी गई है, राइट? उसी
को हम अब पैकेट बोलते हैं। ठीक है? जब
डाटा में हेडर आ गई है, आपकी फुटर आ गई
है, उस हेडर में आपको पता है IP एड्रेस से
रिलेटेड चीजें होती हैं। कोई भी डेटा जो
भी पैकेट होती है उसके हेडर पार्ट में
IPपी एड्रेस से रिलेटेड डिटेल्स होती है।
जैसे सोर्स एड्रेस, डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस
मतलब कहां से आ रही है डेटा? कहां को जानी
है ये सब चीजें होती है। वही हम एड्रेसिंग
की बात यहां पे कर रहे थे। एंड एरर चेकिंग
वगैरह क्या है? कैसे है? वो सारी चीजें
होती है। ठीक है? तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब
इनकैप्सुलेटेड डेटा जो है आपका जिसमें सब
कुछ इंफॉर्मेशनेशन पैक हो चुका है उसको हम
अ पैकेट बोलते हैं। उसको वी विल से इट
पैकेट। इज ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर द फिजिकल
मीडियम टू द रिसीविंग डिवाइस। अब उसी
पैक्ड जो इंफॉर्मेशन है जो डेटा है जिसको
हम पैकेट बोलते हैं उसको ट्रांसमिट कर
दिया जाता है नीचे के लेयर्स के तरफ यानी
कि फिजिकल मीडियम पे यानी जो रिसीविंग
डिवाइस है यानी या कोई सर्वर है या कोई भी
मशीन है उस तक पहुंचा दिया जाता है। अब
रिसीवर साइड क्या है? द प्रोसेस इज़
रिवर्स्ड एज डेटा मूव्स अपवर्ड थ्रू द
ओएसआई लेयर्स। रिसीवर साइड सर्वर के साइड
अब यही प्रोसेस रिवर्स हो जाती है।
क्योंकि अब देखो क्लाइंट से सर्वर को भेजी
जा रही है। राइट? तो यहां पे कहने का मतलब
है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ये क्लाइंट से ये सर्वर तक भेजी जा रही है
कुछ इस डायरेक्शन में। राइट? अब जब फर्स्ट
नंबर पे यह होती है। सेकंड नंबर पर क्या
होगा? अब सर्वर से क्लाइंट के तरफ यह डाटा
जाएगा
तो यह प्रोसेस जो है वह रिवर्स हो जाएगा।
एज़ सिंपल एज़ दैट। ठीक है? इसी को हम बोलते
हैं इनकैप्सुलेशन। ये जो फंडा है क्लाइंट
से सर्वर की तरफ जो डेटा जा रही है उसको
इनकैप्सुलेशन बोलते हैं। सर्वर से जब
क्लाइंट के तरफ जा रही है तो डी
कैैप्सुलेशन बोलते हैं। यानी कि यहां पे
द प्रोसेस। ठीक है? ईच लेयर रिमूव्स इट्स
कॉस्पोंडिंग हेडर या फुटर डीकैप्सुलेशन
अंटिल द ओरिजिनल डाटा इज प्रेजेंटेड टू द
रिसीविंग एप्लीकेशन। तो वही मैंने बताया
कि यहां पे जब सर्वर से क्लाइंट की तरफ जा
रही है तो अब हर लेयर पहले क्या कर रहा
था? इनकैप्सुलेट कर रहा था डेटा की डेटा
को अलग-अलग इनेशन के साथ सर्वर तक आ गई।
सर्वर ने अपना जो भी है देखा पढ़ा उसको
सर्वर को जो भी रिक्वेस्ट आई आया। अब
सर्वर उसको रिस्पॉन्ड कर रहा है क्लाइंट
को उसके रिक्वेस्ट के लिए। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उसको जब डाटा वो
भेजेगा तो यह रिवर्स ऑर्डर हो जाती है। अब
फिजिकल से डाटा लिंक लेयर, नेटवर्क लेयर,
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर, सेशन, प्रेजेंटेशन
फाइनली एप्लीकेशन यानी यूजर तक पहुंच
जाएगी। इसमें फिर ये हर लेयर जो है वो
डेटा को डीकैप्सुलेट करती है। उसको अनरैप
करती है जो मैंने आपको पहले ही बता रखा
है। तो, ईच लेयर रिमूव्स इट्स कॉस्पोंडिंग
हेडर फुटर। अपना कॉस्पोंडिंग हेडर फुटर
रिमूव करता है। अंटिल द ओरिजिनल डेटा इज़
प्रेजेंटेड टू द रिसीविंग एप्लीकेशन। जब
तक कि ओरिजिनल डाटा रिसीविंग एप्लीकेशन तक
ना पहुंच जाए। सो इसी में यह प्रोसेस पूरा
रिवर्स हो जाता है। इसी रिवर्स प्रोसेस को
डीकैप्सुलेशन बोलते हैं। और उधर से जब
क्लाइंट की तरफ से सेंटर साइड से जब ये
प्रोसेस हो रही है तो उसको इनकैप्सुलेशन
बोलते हैं। अब आपको आई थिंक समझ में आ गया
होगा कि इनकैप्सुलेशन क्या होता है?
डीकैप्सुलेशन क्या होता है? ओएसआई मॉडल
में अपवर्ड डाउन मतलब अपवर्ड से डाउनवर्ड
की तरफ क्या होता है? डाउनवर्ड से अपवर्ड
की तरफ किस तरीके से काम करती है? डेटा
किस तरीके से ऊपर से नीचे एप्लीकेशन से
फिजिकल तक आती है। फिर फिजिकल से
एप्लीकेशन तक जाती है। ये पूरा का पूरा
मैटर आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डीड यू गेट
क्लियर हुआ गाइज आपको सभी को? प्लीज मुझे
बताइए। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
प्लीज मुझे बताइए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके गुड गुड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
चलिए ओके बढ़िया है। अ आई थिंक सबको
क्लियर हो गया होगा। एंड आई एम श्योर कि
मैं आपसे एक चीज की ये श्योरिटी आपको दे
सकता हूं कि आई एम श्योर कि आपको अभी जिस
तरीके से मैं समझा रहा हूं इन चीजों को
वैसे आपको बहुत इजी वे में समझ में आ
जाएगा और आपके दिमाग में परमानेंटली बैठ
भी जाएगा। बस इसलिए मैं चाहता हूं कि आप
इन चीजों को थोड़ा समझें और देखें। राइट?
नाउ दिस स्ट्रक्चरर्ड अप्रोच इंश्योर डेटा
इंटीग्रिटी एंड रिलायबिलिटी इवन ओवर
कॉम्प्लेक्स नेटवर्क्स। अब यह जो अह
अप्रोच है, यह डेटा के इंटीग्रिटी को अह
रिलायबिलिटी को अह बेसिकली बेसिकली
इंश्योर करती है। अह जित कितना भी
कॉम्प्लेक्स नेटवर्क हो, उसके ऊपर यह डेटा
की इंटीग्रिटी और रिलायबिलिटी को इंश्योर
करती है। ये एक स्ट्रक्चर फॉलो जब होता है
तो सो दैट्स व्हाई दिस स्ट्रक्चर इज़
वेरीेंट। राइट? चलिए। ओके?
नाउ [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] इसी चीज को
मैंने एक डायग्राम के थ्रू आपको समझाने की
कोशिश करी है ताकि और ज्यादा आपके माइंड
में ये चीज
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
ओके जस्ट अ सेकंड
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
अ इसी को मैंने एक इमेज के थ्रू आपको
समझाने की कोशिश की है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] या कि आप देख
सकते हैं डेटा ट्रांसमिट जब हो रही है तो
अपवर्ड डाउनवर्ड आ रही है एप्लीकेशन लेयर
से सेवंथ लेयर से फर्स्ट लेयर पे आ रही है
जब डेटा यहां से रिसीवर की तरफ जा रहा है
तो मतलब मतलब जो सेंडर है उसकी तरफ जा रहा
है वापस से। तो ये कुछ इस तरीके से फिजिकल
लेयर से से एप्लीकेशन लेयर तरफ जा रही है।
राइट? इसी को हम इनकैप्सुलेशन एंड
डीकैप्सुलेशन
बोलते हैं। आई होप यू अंडरस्टुड दिस थिंग।
राइट?
अब यहां पे हम आते हैं टीसीp आईपी मॉडल
पे। यह एक रियल वर्ल्ड मॉडल कहा जाता है।
क्योंकि रियल वर्ल्ड या करंट अभी जो हम
चीजें करते हैं इंटरनेट पे या जो भी चीजें
हम यूज़ करते हैं एप्लीकेशन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यूज़ करते हैं।
उसमें अह TCPआईपी मॉडल ही यूज़ होता है।
वैसा ही मॉडल एक कॉनंसेप्चुअल मॉडल है।
प्रैक्टिकल मॉडल नहीं है। मतलब इन
प्रैक्टिकल रियल वर्ल्ड में यूज़ नहीं होता
है। बट TCP आईपी मॉडल जो है वही रियल
वर्ल्ड में यूज़ होता है। अब देखो
अब टीसीपीआईपी मॉडल जो है इसमें पांच ही
लेयर होते हैं।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इरेस्पेक्टिव ऑफ
द ओएसआई मॉडल। ओएसआई मॉडल में सात थे बट
इसमें होते हैं सिर्फ पांच लेयर्स। अब
यूज्ड इन रियल नेटवर्क्स इंटरनेट
सिंपलीफाइड वर्जन ऑफ़ ओएसआई। ओएसआई का ही
सिंपली वाइड वर्जन है। एंड रियल नेटवर्क्स
में या इंटरनेट पे यही मॉडल यूज़ में ली
जाती है। अब इसमें पांच लेयर्स कौन-कौन से
होते हैं? मैं अगर टॉप टू बॉटम बात करूं
तो पांचवें पे एप्लीकेशन लेयर होता है।
चौथे पे आपका ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर होता है।
इंटरनेट लेयर होता है। डेटा लिंक लेयर
होती है एंड फिजिकल लेयर होती है। अब ये
लेयर्स जो हैं वो ओएसआई मॉडल्स के जो
लेयर्स हैं उन सब से उन सबके ही सिमिलर
हैं। इसमें भी उन सबसे सिमिलर ही काम होता
है। बट इसको हम थोड़ा अच्छे से समझेंगे कि
बेसिकली ये किस तरीके से रिलेटेड हैं
ओएसआई लेयर से। ये हम समझने की कोशिश
करेंगे। ठीक है? वी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] विल अंडरस्टैंड।
राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके लेट्स सी
[खांसने की आवाज़]
जब हम टीसीपीआईपी लेयर की बात करता हूं
मैं तो मैं यहां पे आपको डिस्कस
करना चाहता हूं कि ये किस तरीके से
टीसीपीआईपी के लेयर्स जो हैं वो मैप करते
हैं ओएसआई लेयर्स के ऊपर में। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एप्लीकेशन लेयर
जो है टीसीपीआईपी का वो ओएसआई के सेवन
सिक्स और फाइव लेयर्स पे मैप करते हैं।
मैं इसको ना डेमोंस्ट्रेट सामने एक इमेज
के थ्रू मतलब जिफ के थ्रू भी बताऊंगा दिखा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] के आपको वो
ज्यादा क्लेरिटी के साथ आपको समझ में
आएगी। तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे एप्लीकेशन लेयर जो है ओएसआई के
फाइव सिक्स से लेयर से मैच करती है मैप
करती है। यानी इसका सबसे टॉप लेयर जो है
वो ए ओएसआई का जो है वो
सेशन प्रेजेंटेशन एंड एप्लीकेशन लेयर इन
तीनों को मैच करती है या इन तीनों पे मैप
होती है। ठीक है?
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर ओएसआई का जो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] फोर्थ लेयर है
आपका ओएसआई का प्रेजेंटेशन
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर उस पर मैप करती है। यानी
ओएसआई का भी ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर ही है जो
यहां का ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर है। इंटरनेट
लेयर जो है ओएसआई के थर्ड यानी कि आई थिंक
नेटवर्क लेयर जो है उस पे मैप करता है। जो
वहां का नेटवर्क लेयर है वो यहां पे आपका
इंटरनेट लेयर है। नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर जो
है ये ओएसआई का वन एंड टू यानी फिजिकल एंड
डेटा लिंक लेयर को डिनोट करता है। तो जो
वहां का फिजिकल एंड डेटा लिंक लेयर्स हैं
आपके वो यहां पे जो है वो
यहां पे क्या होता है आपका नेटवर्क एक्सेस
लेयर से मैप करता है। राइट?
गॉट इट सभी को समझ में आ गया?
एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड यहां पे दोनों के बीच के
डिफरेंसेस समझ में आ गया आपको? मतलब
टीसीपी आईपी लेयर्स जो है वो भी वही है जो
ओएसआई में हमने पढ़ा ना। यहां पे भी वही
चीजें हैं। ट्रांसपोर्ट का मतलब वही है।
एप्लीकेशन का मतलब वही है। नेटवर्क एक्सेस
में हम दो ओएसआई के मॉडल्स को डिस्कस कर
रहे हैं। इंटरनेट लेयर में हम वहां पे के
नेटवर्क लेयर के बारे में डिस्कस कर रहे
हैं। एवरीथिंग द सेम थिंग। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब देखिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यहां पे हम सिर्फ यहां पे इनके जो
लेयर्स हैं उनकी
एप्लीकेशन को समझेंगे थोड़ा एंड एसओसी का
व्यू समझेंगे। सो दैट कि वी अंडरस्टैंड एज
अ टीसीpआईपी मॉडल। तो TCP आई मॉडल के यहां
पे फर्स्ट लेयर जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर में है
की बात कर रहे हैं उसमें हम एचटीपी
एचटीपीएस डीएनएस एफटीपी ये प्रोटोकॉल जो
है उनको इंक्लूड करेंगे जिस तरीके से हमने
ओएसआई में यूज़ किया था प्रोटोकॉल्स
इंक्लूड किए थे वही सेम चीज है सेम फंडा
है सब कुछ सेम है इसलिए मैं यहां पे
डेफिनेशन नहीं आपके लिए लेकर आया डेफिनेशन
मैंने यहां पे नहीं लिखा है सिमिलर थिंग्स
आर देयर राइट एसोसिएट व्यू क्या हो सकता
है वही फिशिंग अटैक्स को देखेगा वो ध्यान
देगा डीएनएस अटैक्स वगैरह को ध्यान देगा
एपीआई अब्यूजस या एपीआई कॉल्स या एपीआई
एनमली
को डिस्क देखेगा। तो जो हमारे ओएसआई मॉडल
में हो रहा था सिमिलर यहां पे एप्लीकेशन
लेयर में सिमिलर टीसीपीआईपी मॉडल में भी
यहां पे आपका सेम जो है वो हो रहा है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में अगेन फिर से जो आपका
ओएसआई में हो रहा था वही यहां पे
टीसीपीआईपी की बात कर रहे हैं यहां पे। तो
प्रोटोकॉल्स टीसीपी यूडीपी ये दोनों आ रही
हैं। एसओसी का व्यू वही सेम चीजें वही आ
रही है। ऑलमोस्ट सेम है। पोर्ट स्कैनिंग,
सीन फ्लड अटैक्स, ट्रैफिक एनमलीज़ या जो भी
नेटवर्क एनमलीज़ हैं वो सारी चीजें इसमें
डिस्कस होती है। तो ये भी सेम है। इंटरनेट
लेयर में यहां पे जो नेटवर्क लेयर था वहां
पे TCP आईपी में जो नेट इंटरनेट लेयर है
वो ओएसआई के नेटवर्क लेयर से मैप करता है।
तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है वहां पे भी हम IPपी
एड्रेसिंग और इन सब चीजों के बारे में कर
रहे तो हम यहां पे भी आईपीस एंड एड्रेसिंग
वगैरह राउटिंग वगैरह की बात करते हैं। तो
सस्िशियस आईपी को देखना मतलब एक्सटर्नल
कम्युनिकेशन बॉट नेट ट्रैफिक्स इन सबको
एनालाइज करना ये सब एसओसी का व्यू है। अगर
आप एसओसी एल वन है तो इंटरनेट लेयर के
बेसिस पे आप इन चीजों को जो है वो ध्यान
में रखेंगे। तो ये आपका इंटरनेट लेयर हो
गया। अब जो है आपका नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर
जो कि मैंने बताया था कि जो कि आपका डाटा
लिंक लेयर या फिर फिजिकल लेयर को डिनोट
करता है क्योंकि आपने यहां पे मैंने पहले
ही बताया था जो चौथा है नेटवर्क एक्सेस वो
टू और वन ओएसआई दोनों को मैप करता है यानी
कि डेटा लिंक एंड फिजिकल लेयर तो यहां पे
हम इसमें मैक एआरपी इथ या जो भी है वो
सबको इंक्लूड करते हैं। तो एयर पीस पूफिंग
इंटरनल अटैक्स इन सब पे ये एसओसी एस एसओसी
जो है इन सबको ध्यान में रखता है। इन सब
पे फोकस करके रखता है। एंड यहां पे भी हम
जो डेटा लिंक और फिजिकल वाली जो काम कर
रहे थे वही काम यहां पे हम कर रहे हैं।
मैक के बारे में बात करेंगे। मैको आईआरपी
वगैरह कोहेड इथरनेट ये सब इसी के अंदर में
आता है नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर में। बस सिंपल
सा फंडा है। तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये यहां पे चार मेन लेयर्स जो थे वो आपके
मैंने आपको टीसी में बताए। हालांकि यहां
पे पांच लेयर्स आपको यहां पे बताए गए हैं।
तो यहां जो फिजिकल लेयर है वो अगेन सेम
फिजिकल लेयर को डिनोट करता है। इसलिए
मैंने यहां पे आपको फिजिकल लेयर कुछ खास
यहां पे मेंशन नहीं किया है क्योंकि वो
सेम फिजिकल लेयर वही है। चार जो लेयर्स है
जिनके बारे में मैंने आपको बताया वो चार
यहां पे मिल गए। और फिजिकल लेयर इज़ फिजिकल
लेयर। फिजिकल लेयर जो आपका ओएसआई में
फिजिकल लेयर है वही आपका यहां पे किस चीज
में फिजिकल लेयर है वो आपका टीसीपीआईपी
में भी फिजिकल लेयर है। राइट? सेम चीज।
हां जी नेटवर्किंग लेयर है। अभी
नेटवर्किंग क्लास है। अभी आपको समझ में आ
रहा है इतनी देर बाद? नेटवर्किंग क्लास कब
से चल रही है? मैंने तो बताया ही था पहले
ही इनफॉर्म कर दिया था सभी को कि
नेटवर्किंग क्लास हो रही है आज से। राइट?
आप थोड़ा लेट आए हैं शायद। बट कोई बात
नहीं नो इशूज़ एट ऑल। अ सो दिस इज ऑल ऑफ
TCP आईपी जो हमने ओएसआई मॉडल में समझा ना
जिन-जिन लेयर्स की वो सब यही लेयर्स हैं
जो यहां पे TCआईपी में बट TCP आईपी में
यहां पे सिर्फ पांच लेयर के बारे में बात
करते हैं जो कि एक रिफाइंड वर्जन है ओएसआई
मॉडल का इसलिए ये TCP आईपी मॉडल अभी रियल
वर्ल्ड इंटरनेट पे यूज़ होता है ना कि
ओएसआई यूज़ होता है राइट तो इसमें हम
एप्लीकेशन ट्रांसपोर्ट इंटरनेट डेटा लिंक
लेयर फिजिकल सबकी डिस्कशन करते हैं।
एप्लीकेशन इज़ एप्लीकेशन। ट्रांसपोर्ट इज़
ट्रांसपोर्ट, इंटरनेट इज़ आपका नेटवर्क
लेयर, डेटा लिंक लेयर एंड फिजिकल लेयर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आई थिंक यह
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। अब यहां पे
ओएसआई एंड TCP के बीच की अगर हम डिफरेंस
की बात करें इंटरव्यू पर्पस से तो मैं
यहां पे इनके फीचर्स को डिस्कस करूंगा।
फीचर्स में अगर हम लेयर्स की बात करें तो
ओएसआई में सात होते हैं। टीसीपीआईपी में
पांच होते हैं। अब यहां पे आपको मैंने चार
दिया है। फिजिकल जो है उसको यहां पे
डिस्क्लूड कर दिया है। फिजिकल को हटा के
यहां पे मैंने मेंशन किया है क्योंकि काम
मेन जो है वो चार है आपके। फिजिकल तो होता
ही होता है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है कि फिजिकल
डिवाइस पे ही कोई कम्युनिकेशन होती है। आप
चाहे तो इसको यहां पे पांच भी लिख सकते
हैं। डजंट मैटर इससे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है। अगर पांच आप लिखना चाहे लिख सकते हैं।
बट यहां पर मैंने इसको चार मेंशन किया है।
मतलब
थोड़ा सा मोर टेक्निकल घुस के मैंने यह चीज
लिख दी है। यूज़ में कंसेप्चुअल यूज़ है
इसका। इसका प्रैक्टिकल यूज़ है। रियल यूज़
में ये लेस यूज़ होता है। ये हाई यूज़ होता
है। बस ये मेन चीज है। अगर हम यहां पे बात
करें। अ
हां। सबसे ज्यादा हाई यूज़ TCP आीआईपी मॉडल
का ही होता है। ठीक है? तो इस चीज़ को लेके
कंफ्यूज मत होइएगा। चार और पांच को लेके।
जैसे मैंने यहां पे स्टार्टिंग में
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देखिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है मैंने
यहां पे स्टार्टिंग में आपको
टीसीp आईपी के यहां पे अ पांच लेयर्स लिखे
थे राइट इसको पांच मैंने लिखा था तो इसको
लेके आप कंफ्यूज मत होइएगा क्योंकि यहां
पे मैं यहां पे जब बात करता हूं नेटवर्क
एक्सेस लेयर इंटरनेट एप्लीकेशन लेयर सब
चीज तो यहां पे
एप्लीकेशन ट्रांसपोर्ट इंटरनेट एंड डेटा
लिंक लेयर या नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर मैं
उसकी बात कर रहा हूं। ठीक है? चार लेयर्स
मेनली उसकी बात कर रहा हूं। तो जब आपसे
कोई पूछेगा तो आप चार लेयर ही बताइएगा।
पांच लेयर मत बोलिएगा। फिजिकल का कोई ऐसा
कॉमन चीज है वो तो होनी ही होनी है।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। उसके बिना कम्युनिकेशन
नहीं होगी। तो यहां पे मेनली हम चार
लेयर्स की बात कर रहे हैं जो कि ओएसआई से
डिराइव्ड है। क्योंकि ओएसआई का रिफाइंड
वर्जन है। तो हम यहां पे चार लिखते हैं।
दैट्स इट। तो अगर कोई पूछे आपसे तो आपको
प्लीज आपको जो है चार ही बोला है। दोनों
के बीच का डिफरेंस क्या है? है। मैंने
ऑलरेडी बता दिया है कि ये चार लेयर्स होते
हैं। इसमें सात होते हैं। यह प्रैक्टिकल
यूज़ केस ज्यादा है। इसका कॉनसेप्चुअल यूज़
केस कॉनसेप्चुअल फॉर्म के लिए वैसा ही है।
ये सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ होता है। ये कम यूज़
बहुत कम यूज़ होता है। रियल यूज़ज़ जो है तो
मेनली जो इंटरनेट आपकी काम करती है वो TCP
आईपी मॉडल पे ही काम करती है। अब इसका मैं
आपको यहां पे एक एग्जांपल दिखाना चाहता
हूं।
सो इफ आई विल गो टू द कंट्रोल सेंटर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अह यहां पे
मैं
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे मैं नेटवर्क एंड शेयरिंग सेंटर की
अगर मैं नेटवर्क एंड शेयरिंग सेंटर ओपन
करूं एंड अगर मैं अपना वाईफाई ये नेटवर्क
जो है इसको ऐसे ओपन करता हूं। यहां पे मैं
अ
प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाता हूं। अब यहां आपको
देखिएगा देखने को मिलेगा आपको यहां पे कि
दिस कनेक्शन यूसेस द फॉलोइंग आइटम्स। ये
फॉलोइंग आइटम्स यूज़ कर रहे हैं। जैसे
क्लाइंट फॉर Microsoft नेटवर्क्स, VMware,
ब्रिज प्रोटोकॉल, फाइल एंड प्रिंट एंड
शेयरिंग ये सब यूज़ कर रहे हैं। इसी में
नीचे की तरफ आप आएंगे तो आपको दिखेगा यहां
पे
यहां पे ये यूज़ करती है इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल
वर्जन 4, TCP IP वर्जन 4, TCP IP वर्जन
सिक्स। तो यहां पे TCP IB वर्जन 4 एंड
वर्जन सिक्स ये यूज़ होती है जो कि आपका
अभी करंट नेटवर्किंग या नेटवर्क में
करेंटली यूज़ में आता है। तो सबसे ज्यादा
यूज़ जो है या या प्रैक्टिकल यूज़ केस की
मैं बात करूं तो दैट इज़ ओनली एंड ओनली TCP
आईपी मॉडल। राइट? ये आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा। चलिए
अब यहां पे एसओसी एग्ज़ांपल एसओसी के
एग्ज़ांपल के अह फॉर्म में देखें यहां पे
तो अगर कोई अलर्ट आता है सस्िशियस लॉग इन
वाया एसटीपीएस फ्रॉम अननोन आईपी ये अलर्ट
आता है तो एसओसी इसको मैप कैसे करेगा एज
एसएससी एसओसी एल1 एज अ एल1 अगर आप एक एल1
है एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट हैं तो आप इसको मैप
करेंगे इस पर्टिकुलर अलर्ट को मैप कैसे
करेंगे अगर आपके पास मैसेज आया सस्पिशियस
लॉग इन वाया एस एचटीपीएस फ्रॉम नोन आईपी
तो मैपिंग में कैसे होगा एप्लीकेशन में
एप्लीकेशन लेयर के लिए किस चीज को मैप
करेंगे एचटीपी लॉग इन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सॉरी
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के लिए आप पोर्ट 443 को
मैप करेंगे। नेटवर्क लेयर के लिए आप
एक्सटर्नल आईपी को
मैप करेंगे। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जो डेटा लिंक है उसके लिए आप इंटरनल
नेटवर्क को मैप करेंगे। तो ये इस तरीके से
मैपिंग करके भी मैंने आपको समझाया है ताकि
कोई एक अलर्ट आ रही है तो उसको आप किस
लेयर के साथ किस तरीके से मैप कर सकते
हैं। दैट्स इट सिमिलर सेम थिंग। ठीक है?
तो आपको समझ में आ चुका होगा। बेसिकली
आपको ये चीज़ समझ में आ चुका होगा। जब
मैपिंग मैंने करके दिखा दिया आपको तो ये
आपको और भी ज्यादा क्लेरिटी के साथ समझ
में आ गई होगी। राइट? आई थिंक आपको
क्लेरिटी मिली यहां से। मैपिंग से कुछ
क्लेरिटी मिली आप लोगों को कि किस तरीके
से यह आप मैप होती है। अगर एप्लीकेशन है
तो एचटीटीp लॉग इन ट्रांसपोर्ट हो रही है
तो पोर्ट के थ्रू हो रही है 443 नेटवर्क
एक्सटर्नल आईपी जो है आपका और डेटा लिंक
जो है इंटरनल नेटवर्क उसको हम करते हैं।
राइट? चलिए ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
नाउ अब यहां पे देखते हैं एसोसिए एनालिस्ट
की थिंकिंग को समझते हैं। एक एसोसिएशन
एनालिस्ट की थिंकिंग उसको समझते हैं। एज अ
थिंक एज एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट आपकी थिंकिंग
क्या होनी चाहिए। व्हनेवर यू सी अ लॉग
ब्रेक इट लाइक। जब भी आप कोई लॉग देखिए तो
इसको ऐसे ब्रेक कीजिए। व्हिच लेयर इज़
इनवॉल्व्ड। आपको इसको ऐसे ब्रेक करना है
कि कौन सी लेयर इनवॉल्वड है। यू हैव टू
ब्रेक डाउन लाइक दिस। एग्जांपल पोर्ट का
इशू है तो ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर इन्वॉल्वड है।
आईपी इशूज़ है तो नेटवर्क लेयर इनवॉल्वड
है। डीएनएस इशूज़ हैं एप्लीकेशन लेयर
इनवॉल्वड है। एआरपी इशूज़ हैं तो डेटा लिंक
लेयर इशूज़ का इनवॉल्वमेंट है। तो इस तरीके
से आपको ब्रेकडाउन करना है। तो आपको मैंने
जो भी अभी आज क्लासेस में अभी तक जो भी
बताई हैं उसमें जब मैंने एक-एक टॉपिक पे
डिस्कशन किया है ना जैसे कि फिजिकल लेयर
की बात की, मैंने, डेटा लिंक लेयर की बात
की, नेटवर्क लेयर की बात की या
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर की बात की। आपको इन सब
लेयर्स के बारे में खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर
करना है। खुद से भी नोट्स बनाने हैं। एंड
जो भी की पॉइंट्स आपको जब ये वीडियो
दोबारा आप रिकॉर्डिंग देखोगे जो कि मैं
रिकमेंड करता हूं कि जब भी आप लाइव
क्लासेस कर लो तो आज ही या अगले दिन कल आप
वीडियोस को दोबारा देखो और तब आप उसके की
पॉइंट्स नोट करो और जो जो मैंने टॉपिक्स
मेनम टॉपिक्स आपको इसमें लग रहे हैं उनको
एनालाइज करके फिर खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर
करो। फिर उसके भी की पॉइंट्स बनाओ, नोट्स
बनाओ और Lindin पे डालो और डिफ़्रॉनिक्स को
या मुझे भी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के साथ-साथ या
सिर्फ डिफ़्रॉनिक जैसे मर्जी टैग जरूर करो
हमें। हमें पता चले और लोगों तक पहुंचाओ
वीडियोस को शेयर करो। लोगों को बताओ कि
भैया ऐसी क्लासेस चल रही हैं जो एक जॉब
रेडी क्लास है। बिल्कुल फ्री में चल रही
हैं। डजंट मैटर। कोई कोई कुछ भी नहीं कोई
पैसा नहीं लिया जा रहा। और लोगों तक फैलाओ
इस चीज को ताकि मैक्सिमम लोगों तक पहुंचे।
बस यही एक मेरी रिक्वेस्ट है। यही एक
उम्मीद है आप लोगों से। दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
चलिए अब यहां पे मैं ये आपसे डिस्कस करता
हूं। ये मेरी बनाई हुई नहीं है। द ऑब्वियस
सी बात है। क्रेडिट गोज़ टू द क्रिएटर
इटसेल्फ। क्रिएटर को सारा क्रेडिट जाता
है। अब यहां पे मैं इसको थोड़ा सा आपको
समझाने की कोशिश करता हूं। ओएसआई वर्सेस
TCP मॉडल को अगर हम इस तरीके से समझे तो
आई थिंक ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ सकते हैं।
एंड लेट्स सी देखो
ओएसआई में ये सात लेयर्स होते हैं। इनके
कलर्स अलग-अलग हैं। जैसे एक थोड़ी सी यहां
पे ग्रीन है, ब्लू है। ये लाइट ऐसे ग्रीन
टाइप ऐसे कुछ बोल सकते हैं। या
देन ब्लू है। देन ये
ऐसे लाइट रेड या ऐसे पर्पल टाइप कुछ भी
बोल सकते हैं। व्हाटएवर यहां पे रेड है
ऐसे करके। ठीक है?
अब यहां पे राइट साइड में टीसीपी मॉडल्स
हैं जिसमें चार मॉडल्स हैं। नेटवर्क
एक्सेस यानी डेटा लिंक वगैरह जो हो गई
इंटरनेट ट्रांसपोर्ट एंड एप्लीकेशन। तो जब
हम बात करते हैं यहां पे ये जैसे ग्रीन
वाली है। ठीक है? ग्रीन वाली लेयर से इसके
अंदर में यानी कि ओएसआई के अंदर में तो ये
एप्लीकेशन हो गया आपका मेन आपका इस कलर का
और इधर से राइट साइड में टीसीपी से आपका
ये एप्लीकेशन हो गया। इसमें क्या-क्या
कंटेन होता है? डीएसीपी, डीएनएस, एफटीपी,
एचटीडीटीp, एचटीडीपीएस, पॉप, एसएमटीपी,
एसएसए, एचटीएमएल, जीपी, जीटीसी यह सारे
प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज़ में होते हैं। जब हम यहां
पे ब्लू की बात करते हैं यहां पे इस वाले
थोड़े से इस वाले ब्लू की हम जब बात करते
हैं या इस वाले ब्लू की बात करते हैं, तो
हम यहां पे टीसीपी यूडीपी की बात करते
हैं। वी आर टॉकिंग अबाउट दिस डार्क ब्लू।
तो डार्क ब्लू की जब हम बात करते हैं तो
ट्रांसपोर्ट की बात करते हैं तो यहां पे
टीसीपी यूडीपी की बात करते हैं। जब मैं
यहां पे इस टाइप से पर्पल टाइप थोड़ा सा
कलर है उस टाइप में बात करते हैं तो हम
यहां पे नेटवर्क या इंटरनेट लेयर की बात
करते हैं। नेटवर्क एंड इंटरनेट लेयर में
आपकी IPपी एड्रेस जो एड्रेसिंग है वो अभी
फॉर वर्जन सिक्स उसकी बात कर रहे हैं।
डेटा यहां पे ये जो कलर है लाइट ग्रीन
टाइप कलर जिसमें हम फिजिकल या नेटवर्क
एक्सेस लेयर की बात करते हैं। तो उसमें हम
इथर केबल मैक एड्रेसेस की बात करते हैं।
फाइबर की बात करते हैं। वायरलेस के बारे
में बात करते हैं। RJ45, एसडीएच,
डीएसएलएल, डीएसएल ये सब चीजों के बारे में
बात करते हैं। तो ये एक एक तरह से एक
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन है काइंड ऑफ़ जो आपको
डेमोंस्ट्रेट करता है दोनों लेयर्स के बीच
के डिफरेंसेस को, दोनों लेयर्स के बीच के
एग्जांपल्स को ओएसआई एंड टीसीपी के जिसमें
कि टीसीपी मॉडल रियल वर्ल्ड में यूज़ होने
वाला मॉडल है। करेंटली यूज़ होता है
मोस्टली। एंड इसी मॉडल को फॉलो किया जाता
है। राइट? तो ये एग्जांपल के थ्रू आपको
ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ में आ गया होगा कि
जिसमें कॉमन जो है वो एप्लीकेशन,
ट्रांसपोर्ट, इंटरनेट एंड नेटवर्क एक्सेस
जिसके एग्जांपल यहां पे आपके दे रखे हैं।
बस दैट्स इट। ये आपका क्लियर हो गया होगा।
तो ये सब कुछ मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए।
क्लियर हो गया? यहां पे एंड ऑफ़ स्लाइड है।
दैट्स इट। ये दोनों के बीच की मैंने आपको
डिफरेंसेस दोनों के बीच की मैंने आपको
डिटेल्स एंड सारी चीजें बताई हैं। ओएसआई
मॉडल क्या होता है? क्या कौन-कौन से
लेयर्स हैं? उन्हीं लेयर्स के जो कॉमन
लेयर्स चार लेयर्स आपके हो जाते हैं। जो
टीसीp के लेयर्स हैं उसके बारे में मैंने
आपको बताया जिसमें एप्लीकेशन लेयर,
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर, इंटरनेट लेयर एंड
नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर होता है। बेसिकली
नेटवर्क एक्सेस लेयर बोल लो या डेटा लिंक
लेयर बोल दो बोथ आर ऑलमोस्ट सेम। ठीक है?
जो भी है आप सेम बोल सकते हो। नो इशूज़। तो
ये चीजें आपको समझ में आ गई होंगी। राइट?
आई होप सो कि आपको बहुत ईजीली समझ में आ
गई होंगी। इनके एग्जांपल्स आपको समझ में आ
गई होंगी। किस लेवल पे क्या चीजें हम
डिस्कस करते हैं वो चीजें समझ में आ गई
होंगी कि अगर हम नेटवर्क एक्सेस की बात
करें तो हम यहां पे मैक एआरp की बात करें
इंटरनेट में आईपी वगैरह की बात कर रहे
हैं। ट्रांसपोर्ट में ईटीसी ओडीपी की बात
करें। एप्लीकेशन में हम अलग-अलग
प्रोटोकॉल्स जैसे http, https, डीएनए,
एफटीp इन सब की बातें करते हैं। एंड ओएसआई
में अगर हम जब देख रहे थे तो ओएसआई में भी
मैंने पूरे डिटेल में आपको बताया है।
एप्लीकेशन लेयर में फिर वही सारी चीजें
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर में आपका डेटा
फॉर्मेटिंग, इंक्रिप्शन डिक्रिप्शन या जो
भी है आपका कररेक्टर इंकोडिंग या डेटा
इंक्रिप्शन इन सब के बारे में। सेशन लेयर
में सेशंस वगैरह के बारे में, डेटा
एक्सचेंज सिंक्रोनाइज़्ड फॉर्म में हो रही
है। एप्लीकेशनेशंस कम्युनिकेट इफ़ेक्टिवली
कर रहे हैं। ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में डीसीपी,
यूडीपी की बात करी। नेटवर्क लेयर में हमने
IP फॉर्मेट IP एड्रेसेसिंग एड्रेसिंग हो
गई राउटिंग हो गई। इन सब के बारे में बात
करी। डेटा लिंक में हमने मैक एड्रेस
कम्युनिकेशन या फिजिकल कम्युनिकेशन या
उसके बारे में बात करी हमने। जो लोकल
कम्युनिक नेटवर्क कम्युनिकेशन है ईच अदर
से उसके बारे में बात करी। फिजिकल लेयर
में हमने बेसिकली हार्डवेयर ट्रांसमिशन या
हार्डवेयर्स के बारे में बात करी है। जहां
पे एक्चुअली जीरो वन का ट्रांसमिशन होता
है। जो बाइनरी डिजिट का ट्रांसमिशन होता
है। दोनों के बीच में हमने यहां पे
बेसिकली ओएसआई का ये तीन फ्रेमवर्क जो तीन
स्टेप्स हैं सेंडर्स ट्रांसमिशन एंड
रिसीवर्स वो देखा। इनकैप्सुलेशन
डीकैप्सुलेशन समझा। देन हमने टीसीpआपी
मॉडल को समझा। किस तरीके से टीसीपीआईपी
मॉडल्स कौन-कौन से टीसीपी लेयर्स किस
ओएसआई मॉडल में मैप्ड हैं वो हमने देखा।
यहां पे चार लेयर्स होते हैं वो हमने
चारों लेयर्स को समझा। दोनों के बीच के
डिफरेंसेस को समझा। देन एसओसी की मैपिंग
देखी एंड देन हमने एनालिस्ट थिंकिंग को
देखा एंड इसको एक जीफ से हमने समझने की
कोशिश करी। सो आई होप आपको सारा कुछ
क्लियर हो गया होगा। एंड आई थिंक कि आप अब
से इन मॉडल्स को ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ
पाएंगे और जब आप इसको अपने से खुद से भी
थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर करेंगे तो आप इसको और भी
ज्यादा अच्छे से समझेंगे। मेरी यही आपसे
उम्मीद है। तो, आपका एक टास्क यह है कि
मैंने जितने भी इंपॉर्टेंट लेयर्स एंड
टॉपिक्स मैंने आपको बताएं, जो लेयर्स के
नाम बताएं, आप उन सब लेयर्स को एक-एक करके
एक्सप्लोर करेंगे। वीडियो को वापस से जब
देखेंगे तो कमेंट तो कर ही दीजिएगा। यूनिक
कमेंट्स कर दीजिएगा। शेयर जरूर कर
दीजिएगा। जिनके जिनके बीच करते हैं आप।
मैक्सिमम शेयर कीजिएगा और उसके
स्क्रीनशॉट्स रखिएगा क्योंकि जब बिगिवे का
अनाउंसमेंट होगा तो आपको स्क्रीनशॉट मांगा
जाएगा आपसे। जिसके सबसे ज्यादा शेयर्स
होंगे ऑब्वियस सी बात है टॉप थ्री को हम
चूज़ करेंगे एंड वी विल गिव देम समथिंग
यूज़फुल। तो आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ गया।
राइट?
ठीक है। ओके।
राइट।
चलिए। ओके। सो, यहां पे मैं इसको डिस्कार
करता हूं। ओके। मैं यहां पर आ जाता हूं
चैट पे एंड यहां पर मैं टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट
पर चला जाता हूं। बाय आफ्टर
टॉपिंग आउट द चैट। लेट्स सी द टॉप फैंस
लिस्ट यहां पे।
अगेन आई थिंक मैं यहां पे थोड़ा जल्दी में
आज बोलूंगा यहां पे। मैं यहां पे सबके नाम
नहीं ले ले पाऊंगा। इसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी। बट यहां पे मैं आपको सबका नाम दिखा
देता हूं। जैसे फोर्स स्कल एंड पीतांबर
एंड मिस्टर रोबोट विष्णु चौधरी से निशा
चौधरी ये सब है जगतगुरु स्वामी आशीष एंड
इन सब से लेके एंड यहां तक नीचे जो है आप
आएंगे तो लास्ट में आपका कोड एरर एंड आयान
इकबाल साइबर डिफेंडर ये सब इन यहां पे टॉप
फैंस लिस्ट में है एंड थैंक यू वेरी मच
फॉर अ ऑलवेज
गेटिंग इंगेज्ड वि द लाइव सेशंस एंड कमिंग
हियर एंड आई होप कि आप इसी तरीके से अपनी
मेंटेन करेंगे अटेंडेंस को, अपनी प्रेजेंस
को ताकि मुझे भी मजा आता रहे। एंड कैसे भी
तरीके से कुछ भी करके मैं आपके लिए वीडियो
तो लेकर आता रहूंगा बट आप अपने प्रॉमिस को
फुलफिल कीजिएगा तभी। सो बस दैट्स इट।
प्लीज फुलफिल योर प्रॉमिस टू कमेंट। यूनिक
और जेन्युइन कमेंट्स प्लीज कीजिएगा। 200
प्लस कमेंट्स एंड आपको कैसा लगता है यह
ट्रेनिंग? कैसी लगती है क्लासेस? आप
कमेंट्स में वो भी लिख सकते हैं।
ठीक है? अगर आपने कोई इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोज़र बग रिपोर्ट किया था और अभी तक
कंपनी की तरफ से रिस्पांस नहीं आया तो आप
एक बार उनको रिमाइंड कराइए। अगर फिर भी
नहीं आता तो यह कंपनी के अब ऊपर डिपेंड
करता है। कई ऐसी कंपनीज़ होती है जो रिसोंड
सही से नहीं करती है। ऐसी कंपनीज़ को छोड़
दीजिए। ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स पे हंट मत कीजिए।
सो बस आज के लिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इतना ही
गाइस। आई एम नॉट फीलिंग दैट वेल। सो आई एम
नॉट गोइंग टू टॉक ज्यादा। आज बहुत ज्यादा
बात नहीं हो सकती है। तो मैं सेशन को थोड़ा
एंड करता हूं यहां पे। एंड बस लाइक ठोकते
हुए चले जाइएगा। सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिएगा
नहीं करा होगा तो और नहीं तो बेल आइकॉन
वगैरह देख लीजिएगा। ऑल नोटिफिकेशन हो।
दैट्स इट। थैंक्स एवरीवन एंड हैव अ गुड
नाइट। शुभ रात्रि। टाटा बाय-ब टेक केयर।